MEETING TO ORDER WHERE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET SO WE JUST
DEAL WITH INFORMATIONAL ITEMS --
WHEN THE MEMBERS COME WE WILL --
DEFINITELY TAKE ROLE WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
MEETINGS HAPPENING AT THE SAME
TIME SO MEMBERS THE DOING DOUBLE
DUTY -- SO TO BEGIN WITH OUR
AGENDA HERE FOR MARCH THE TWENTY
FIFTH OF WE'RE ASKING THIS IS
DEALING WITH THE JUDICIAL BRANCH.
SO WE CAN BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING AND COURT
REPORTERS.
WE HAVE -- SPEAKING WITH US
TODAY SOMEONE FROM THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND THEN MEMBERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
MEMBERS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WELCOME TO THE HEARING GOOD TO
SEE YOU ALL ON MONDAY.
MAKING IT A REGULAR DATE.
OKAY WILL BEGIN.
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER AND THE
NUMBER STONE.
NAME IS LOT COMPUTER WHICH ON
THE BUDGET DIRECTOR FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH AND I HAVE WITH
ME -- MISTER MIKE RODDY -- COURT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FROM THE SAN
DIEGO COURT.
WE HEAR RESPOND TO THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE POSED IN THE AGENDA
REGARDING THE FIRST ISSUE ON THE
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION FOR INCLUDING THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET THIS PAST YEAR.
IT'S BEEN A TREMENDOUS HELP IN
AN IMPROVING ACCESS TO JUSTICE
TO OUT OUR OUR COURT SYSTEM.
WITH THAT SAID -- SORT OF
RESPOND TO THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE POSED.
THE FIRST QUESTION WAS REGARDING
THE ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY THAT
THE COUNCIL USED ON THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION -- FIRST A THREE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS WAS
USED TO BRING UP -- OUR SMALLEST
COURTS TO THEIR FUNDING NEED
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT THERE --
BUT 800-800-1000 -- TO HELP SOME
SECURITY COSTS THAT ARE HEADING
COURTS.
AND THEN THE THE BALANCE OF
SEVENTY POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN DISCRETIONARY FUNDS.
WERE DISTRIBUTED TO THE
REMAINING COURTS -- ON A
PROPORTIONAL BASIS.
AND THE COUNCIL THAT ACTS TO
SEPARATELY ALLOCATE TEN MILLION
OF THE SEVENTY POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. TO INCREASE THE LEVEL
OF COURT REPORTER FOR A REFORM
COURT REPORTERS IN FAMILY LAW.
CONSISTENT WITH THE BUDGET
LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET ACT -- TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE THE AGENDA
DOES CORRECTLY IDENTIFY THE
COURTS THAT RECEIVE THE FUNDS --
WE WORK WITH STAFF TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO BREAK DOWN
ALL OF THE DOLLARS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET.
AND IN TERMS OF EXPENDITURES OF
COURT REPORTER FUNDS TO DATE --
WE DON'T HAVE SINCE WERE MADE
HERE IN THE FISCAL YEAR DON'T
HAVE EXPENDITURE DATA -- IN
TERMS OF WHERE COURTS ARE IN
TERMS OF EXPENDITURES WHO DO
HAVE SOME SORT OF WITH PROVIDING
YOU SEE IN THE AGENDA SOME --
ANTICIPATED HOPEFUL OUTCOMES AND
PLANS -- FOR THE EXPENDITURE IF
YOU CALL LAST YEAR -- DOCTOR
WHERE WILL BE PROVIDED ON WHAT
WERE CALLED BUDGET SNAPSHOTS
EACH COURT DID IDENTIFY WHAT
THEY WOULD BE SPENDING THEIR
MONEY ON IN ANTICIPATION OF AN
INVESTMENT WE PROVIDED YOU THAT
AS A SORT OF A YOU KNOW A LOOK
BACK AS TO WHAT WAS DONE -- AS
FAR SOME OUTCOMES WITHOUT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION IN TERMS OF
EXPANDING ACCESS -- INCREASING
STAFFING WE HIRING -- EMPLOYEE
SALARIES CASE MANAGEMENT
EXTENDING SERVICE DAYS NOW --
BUT NOT SO I THINK THERE'S SOME
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS THERE AND
COURTS REALLY USING THOSE
RESOURCES.
TO HELP BRING ABOUT AN
AFFECTIONATE SOME GOOD CHANGE
FOR THE FOR THE BRANCH WITH
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SURE HAD RESPOND ANY QUESTIONS
AND HAVE AN AGAIN.
ANY COMMENTS FROM LA -- OR
CORPORATE FINANCE.
THE REQUESTED MRS STONE.
JUST.
SINCE YOU HANDED OUT THIS BINDER
WHICH IS PRETTY INTERESTING I
WAS ONLY IF I CAN GET THAT
ELECTRONICALLY ABSOLUTELY AND IF
WE COULD.
IF THIS IS SOMETHING THIS IS A
GREAT RESOURCE AND IF YOU I I
HOPE YOU CONTINUE TO DO THAT
ESPECIALLY AS WE STRUGGLE WITH
COURTS FUNDING.
BECAUSE THIS REALLY LETS US KNOW
THE TRIAL COURT LEVEL.
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE FACING
AS WELL AS THEIR PRIORITIES FOR
REINVESTMENT SO IF WE COULD GET
THIS FOR EARLY RIDERS IS THE AS
A PART OF THAT.
BUDGET PROCESS I DON'T KNOW WHEN
YOU COLLECT THIS RECORDED THIS
WAS A IN THIS YEAR.
IF I MAY UM DOCTOR AGAINST ONLY --
WE DID IT SORT OF UNIQUELY FOR
THIS LAST BUDGET ADVOCACY GIVEN
THAT TYPE IN NATURE OF THERE WAS
A DISCRETIONARY FUNDING WE
DEFINITELY WANTED TO COMMUNICATE.
TO THE LEGISLATURE THE
MINISTRATION WHAT WERE THE SORT
OF SPECIFIC GOALS -- SO WE TEND
TO TAILOR OUR ADVOCACY BASED ON
WHAT'S IN THE BUDGET AND SO THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET DOESN'T HAVE THE
SAME TYPE OF OF PRESENTATION SO
IT.
AGAIN WE HADN'T SORT OF TAILOR
OUR INFORMATION BUT WE ARE
GATHERING INFORMATION AS
REQUESTED BY THE COUNCIL FROM
ALL OF THE COURTS AS TO WHAT
THEY DID.
AND SO I THINK THAT THAT WOULD
BE -- SOMETHING WE SHARED WITH
THE STAFF AND WE CAN DEFINITELY
PASS IT ON TO YOU OKAY -- AS WE
GO GREAT THAT'S HELPFUL BECAUSE
WE TYPICALLY TALK WHICH IS A
COUNSEL S WE GO THROUGH BUDGET
STUFF BUT THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
WE'RE HEARING FROM TRIAL COURTS
INDEED BOTH OURS AND ACROSS THE
STATE.
IN MAKING SURE THAT THAT WE HAVE
A SENSE OF WHAT IT IS A TRIAL
COURTS ARE WANTING TO DO AND
THEN AS WE TALK TO YOU THAT THAT
DOES HELP US.
KIND OF KEEP TRACK OF WHERE
THINGS ARE INDEED SO WHATEVER IS
APPROPRIATE.
I FIND THIS VERY INTERESTING AND
I HOPE WE CAN THIS LEVEL OF
DETAIL.
IS HELPFUL UNDERSTOOD.
IN THIS THIS BOOKLET THAT WE'VE
BEEN GIVEN IS THE CURRENT
CHALLENGES THEY FACE IT WAS.
AND WHAT THEY WOULD DO WITH
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS COMING IN
THIS YEAR IT WAS IT WAS THE
REPRESENTATION OF LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET OKAY BECAUSE WE ARE
LOOKING IN THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
THIS WAS LOOKING BACKWARDS AT
THE MONEY THAT WAS APPROPRIATED.
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND SO WE
WANTED WITH THOSE IMPORTANT TO
TO TO EXPLAIN TO WHAT WE THOUGHT
WE WERE GOING TO DO POSITIVELY
WITH THE MONEY THAT WAS IN THE
BUDGET -- PRISON WITH YOU KNOW
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
CHALLENGES THAT WILL.
PROCESS BUT WITH THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WE MAKING A SIGNIFICANT
HEADWAY TOWARDS MEETING THESE
NEEDS THAT WERE PRESENTED HERE
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING IS THE
COUNCIL REQUIRED TO REPORT IN
TERMS OF OUTCOMES.
AND SO WE ARE GATHERING
INFORMATION BACK FROM THE COURTS
BUT WHAT THEY ARE DOING AND
PLANNING TO DO WITH THE MONEY.
OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YEAH I DON'T HAVE ANY THAT ARE
ANY OF COMMENTS FROM THE
AUDIENCE.
WILL EACH HAVE A MINUTE.
TO IT WAS COMMON.
HI -- NANCY TRAVEL WITH CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA I HOPE
THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE TIME --
MY COLLEAGUE FROM DEFENSE
COUNSEL MIKEBELOW NIGHT
SPECIFICALLY WANTED TO SPEAK TO
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL TRIAL
COURT JUDGES -- WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS YEAR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IS OFFICIALLY ASKING FOR
TWENTY FIVE ADDITIONAL JUDGES
WAY BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN THERE WERE FIFTY
AUTHORIZED ONLY TWO OF THOSE
FIFTY HAVE EVER BEEN FUNDED.
AND SO DURING THE MANY YEARS OF
BUDGET CUTS IT WAS VERY
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WAS NOT ABLE TO
APPROPRIATE FUNDS FOR JUDGES BUT
NOW.
THAT TWELVE YEARS HAVE PASSED
AND WE HAVE A NEW GOVERNOR.
ON WE THINK IT'S FAR PAST TIME
TO FUND THOSE DESPERATELY NEEDED
TRIAL COURT JUDGES VERTICALLY
SINCE THE IDENTIFIED NEED.
IS APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN AND AS REPRESENTING
LAWYERS WHO PRACTICE IN CIVIL
COURTS WHETHER IT'S PERSONAL
INJURY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ELDER
ABUSE -- SEX DISCRIMINATION OUR
CASES ALWAYS ARE FALLING TO THE
LAST OF THE PACK -- AFTER
CRIMINAL CASES WHICH OF COURSE
HAVE THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PREFERENCE SO WE HOPE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
BOTH THE GOVERNOR AND THIS
COMMITTEE WILL CONSIDER.
OF FINDING THOSE ADDITIONAL
TWENTY FIVE JUDGES THEIR SHARE
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MIKE
BELOW AGAIN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL AND
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION.
AGAIN FROM THE DESIGN OF THE
AGENDA WE WEREN'T SURE EXACTLY
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE TIME WAS TO
SPEAK TO THIS JUDGESHIP ISSUE --
BUT I WOULD SECOND WHAT -- IS
TRAVEL WAS TALKING ABOUT THROUGH
THE GREAT RECESSION.
THE CIVIL FILING FEES WERE
INCREASED.
REPEATEDLY BUT BECAUSE OF THE
DEMANDS ON THE COURTS ESPECIALLY --
CRIMINAL SPEEDY TRIAL
REQUIREMENTS SERVICE TO CIVIL
LITIGANTS ACTUALLY WENT DOWN SO
HIGHER FEES LOWER SERVICE WE
UNDERSTOOD IT BUT NOW WE'RE IN A
NEW ERA -- WE ARE HAVING TROUBLE
GETTING MOTIONS HER TRIAL DATE
SET AND SO AS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A JUDICIAL BRANCH FUNDING
SORT OF WRIT LARGE AGAIN IT IS
NOT A DISCRETIONARY FUNDING
ISSUE.
BUT IT IS AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT
OF JUDICIAL BRANCH FUNDING AND
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO OF FOR THIS FIRST TIME NOW
THAT WERE PASSED THE RECESSION.
TO FUND HALF OF THE AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS THAT WOULD BE TWENTY
FIVE JUDGESHIPS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING -- THANK YOU FOR
HAVING HERE MY NAME IS SCOTT
THOMAS I'M A COURT INVESTIGATOR
WITH CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT.
AND I'M HERE BECAUSE I LIKE TO
MAKE YOU AWARE OF THE SMALL
GROUP OF EMPLOYEES THAT EVEN
MANY COURT EMPLOYEES ARE UNAWARE
OF COURT INVESTIGATORS DEAL WITH
AT RISK -- PEOPLE WE DEAL WITH
CHILDREN AND ADULTS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED ADULTS AND THE ELDERLY.
UNLIKE CHILDREN DAHLE PROTECTIVE
SERVICES.
AND THE POLICE CANNOT REMOVE
INDEPENDENT ADULT FROM A RISKY
SITUATION IN THEIR HOME -- THEY
DEPEND ON THE POINT OF
CONSERVATIVES BY THE COURT TO
LOOK AFTER THEIR WELFARE.
CORDON BEST GATORS ARE TASKED
WITH LOOKING AFTER THE
CONSERVATIVES WERE MANDATED BY
PROBATE CODE THE VISIT
CONSERVATIVES CONSERVATORIES IN
THEIR HOME EVERY TWO YEARS.
I'M NOT AWARE OF A SINGLE COURT
THAT IS IN COMPLIANCE WITH THIS
MANDATE WE HAD CHALLENGES WITH
THIS MANDATE DUE TO SHORTAGES OF
PERSONNEL BEFORE TRIAL COURT
FUNDING.
AND WE ARE CONTINUING STRUGGLE
TO MEET THESE DEMANDS.
SO WHEN YOU CONSIDER ADDITIONAL
FUNDING -- IT CAN TAKE CENTER
THIS SITUATION IT CONCERNS ME
GREATLY LAST YEAR.
WE HAD AN ELDERLY GENTLEMAN --
DIE OF NEGLECT IN A CARE HOME.
HE WAS FOUND ON A MATTRESS ON
THE FLOOR IN HIS OWN URINE --
VISITS OR SHOULD BE TAKING PLACE
EVERY TWO YEARS ARE ROUTINELY
BEING PUSHED OFF THE FOUR YEARS
SIX YEARS -- THIS IS AN AT RISK
POPULATION JUST CAN'T RISK THAT
KIND OF TIME FRAME.
SO I APPRECIATE ANY
CONSIDERATION YOU CAN GIVE TO
THE FUNDING THAT WOULD HELP
SUPPORT THE COURT INVESTIGATIONS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE
CHAIRMAN DOCTOR WEBER AND
ESTEEMED MEMBERS OF OUR SIMPLY
MY NAME IS LESLIE MAYBE I
PRESIDENT OF ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
AND I HAVE PROBABLY SERVED AS A
COURTROOM CLERK FOR TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS OF ORANGE COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT.
I APPRECIATE LAST YEAR'S
INVESTMENT IN THE COURTS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S CURRENT INCREASED
INVESTMENT.
HOWEVER WE'RE STILL EXCEEDINGLY
FAR BEHIND WHERE WE NEED TO BE
IN ORDER TO RESTORE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE.
SPECIFICALLY ORANGE COUNTY THIS
IS IMPACTED OUR COMMUNITY IN
SEVERAL WAYS.
WITH LESS EXPERIENCED STAFF AND
INCREASED TURNOVER OF MANY DUE
TO RETIREMENTS BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY THEY'RE BURNED OUT.
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE WAIT LONGER
FOR CASE RESOLUTION AS OF THE
ONE OF THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
STATED IN CIVIL DIVISION THERE'S
A TWO YEAR BACKLOG.
AND IN THE SOUTHERN PART OF
ORANGE COUNTY THE REGIONAL
COURTHOUSES BEEN CLOSED
IMPACTING SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
CAP ARE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
THEIR DIRECT ABILITY. TO REACH
LET ALONE ACCESS JUSTICE.
THESE SERVICES IMPACTS HAVE EVEN
BECAUSE TIMES WERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS ARE HAVING
EXPERIENCE UNNECESSARY DELAYS
BECAUSE THEY THEY COME IN AT THE
END OF THE DAY TO GET A WARRANT.
SIGNED BY JUDICIAL OFFICER OF
THE COURT ROOMS ARE CLOSED DOWN
BY FOUR THIRTY COURT ROOM.
CASE PROCESSING IS CLOSE BY.
FOR AND THEY THE SERVER DEALING
WITH.
THEM NOT GETTING THE WARRANTS
THAT THEY NEED.
AND WE'RE KNOW THAT WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S COMPETING PRIORITIES OUT
THERE -- WE HAVE AN ADDED
PRESSURE ON OUR BUDGET AS OUR
COURT IS HIRING SOME ELEVEN
COMMISSIONERS TO HANDLE THE
WORKLOAD.
WELL THOSE ELEVEN COMMISSIONERS
THAT COMES OUT OF THE TRIAL
COURT REVENUE.
WHERE AS IF IT WAS A JUDICIAL
OFFICER A JUDGE IT WOULD COME
OUT OF STATE FUNDING?
SO.
I I MY IBS THE BEST THING I CAN
SAY TO YOU IS THAT I I IMPLORE
YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE ADDRESS.
THE FUNDING FOR THE COURTS AND
HOW IT IMPACTS THE RESIDENTS OF
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SYLVIA RUSSO
I WORK FOR CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
COURTS.
I'M A COURT REPORTER I'M AN
OFFICIAL AND I'M A REAL TIME
COURT REPORTER.
AND ALL RIGHT I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT OUR COURT HAS BEEN IN A
SLUMP FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
WE ARE IN DESPERATE NEED OF
FUNDING.
AND WE ARE HERE IN COALITION
WITH AT THE AYE YOU.
TEN TWENTY OUR UNION AND WE ARE
HERE TODAY TO LET YOU KNOW HOW
THIS PERSONALLY AFFECTS US.
I AM NOT HERE IN ANY WAY TO BE
GREEDY.
BUT I AM HERE TO THAT LET YOU
KNOW THAT OUR PAY IS NOT IN LINE
WITH INFLATION AND THE COST OF
LIVING.
I MYSELF.
I'M GONNA EXPLAIN SOME OF MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES THAT.
I HAVE PLACED ON ME.
AND AS A SINGLE MOM I HAVE A
DISABLED SON I HAVE TWO KIDS
I'VE NEVER BEEN ABLE TO AFFORD
TO BUY A HOME.
I DRIVE A CAR THAT HAS TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND PLUS
MILES ON IT.
AND WE ARE LIVING IN DESPERATE
TIMES IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
LIVING IN THE SITUATIONS.
BRINGS FAMILIES AND PEOPLE FROM
OUR COMMUNITIES INTO OUR COURTS.
AND THROUGH THESE DESPERATE
TIMES IT'S JUST IMPACTING OUR
COURTS.
AND ARM.
GASES THAT FOOD IS THAT AND
RIGHT NOW I AM AND QUIRK I'M
QUESTIONING HOW.
AN AB QUESTION THIS MANY TIMES
WHEN I GO OUT SHOPPING HOW I'M
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BUY FOOD.
I THOUGHT WHEN I PURSUE THIS
CAREER THAT I WAS GONNA BE OKAY
AND THAT I WAS GOING TO HAVE.
YOU KNOW ENOUGH MONEY TO SUPPORT
ME AND MY CHILDREN AS A SINGLE
MOTHER.
BUT I AM HERE TO ASK ALL OF YOU
TO SUPPORT OUR COURT WORKERS.
WITHOUT.
US COURT REPORTERS IN COURT
WORKERS IN THE WORKFORCE THERE
IS NO ACCESS TO JUSTICE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AUDIBLE MET MADAM
WEBER.
IN MEMBERS OF AB AB.
CHAIRMAN CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS BRIDGET WASHINGTON I AM A
SENIOR LABOR RELATIONS
REPRESENTATIVE WITH THE LABOR
UNION ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
FIGHTING RESIDENTS ACCESS TO AN
ACCURATE RECORD OF COURT
PROCEEDINGS IS CRITICAL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE.
HOWEVER IN TWENTY THIRTEEN COURT
REPORTER POSITIONS HAVE BEEN
ELIMINATED.
AND THEIR HOURS WERE REDUCED TO
THIRTY FIVE HOURS.
THAT MEANT PROCEEDINGS WERE CUT
SHORT RESIDENTS WERE ASKED TO
LEAVE.
AND COME BACK THE NEXT DAY.
WITNESSES STOPPED MID TESTIMONY
IN CASES WHERE DELAYED
UNNECESSARILY.
RECENTLY AN ORANGE COUNTY COURT
REPORTERS HOURS WERE RESTORED
BACK TO FORTY HOURS.
BUT DESPITE THE ADDITIONAL HOURS
THE IMPACTS TO THE PUBLIC REMAIN.
FINDING THE COURTS SERVICES WILL
HELP JURISDICTIONS LIKE ORANGE
COUNTY RESTORE SERVICES.
SO I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF COURT
REPORTERS -- ONE WAS UNABLE TO
ATTEND BECAUSE OF REDUCE
STAFFING.
BUT WE ARE ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ENOUGH THAT YOU WOULD
SUPPORT THAT'S AN ORANGE COUNTY
AND THE FIFTY TRIAL COURTS IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY MY NAME IS CINDY
TO SHALL I'M AN OFFICIAL COURT
REPORTER WITH LOS ANGELES
SUPERIOR COURT.
A MEMBER OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
COURT REPORTERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA COURT PORTERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND S. CI YOU. SEVEN TWENTY ONE
FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS I'VE
BEEN A COURT REPORTER IN FAMILY
LAW.
AND I WAS THE FIRST REPORTER IN
MY COURT HOUSE TO REPORT A
JAMISON VERSES DESTA CASE FOR AN
INDIGENT CIVIL.
LITIGANT.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND THE LITIGANT WAS.
RECEIVED A TRANSCRIPT RIGHT AWAY
AND WAS VERY HAPPY TO RECEIVE IT.
I CAN TELL YOU OVER ALL THE
COURT REPORTERS ARE THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR MAKING THE RECORD.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE
SPEAK INTO OUR CELL PHONES FOR
TOO LONG.
REPORTERS ARE ACCURATE REPORTERS
ARE TIMELY PORTERS ARE
PROFESSIONAL [inaudible]
THE SERVICE.
MOSTLY IN FAMILY LAW NON
REPRESENT AND NON REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS AND THEY REQUIRE
TRANSCRIPTS ALL THE TIME IN
FAMILY LAW WE'RE DOING DEALING
WITH VERY SERIOUS ISSUES.
MORE THAN JUST CHILD CUSTODY.
MENTAL ILLNESS ADDICTION.
AND THE LIKE.
SO I'D MEET WITH OR SPEAK WITH A
LOT OF LITIGANTS EVERY DAY AND
HEAR FROM A LOT OF LITIGANTS
EVERY DAY IT'S ONE OF MY
PRIORITIES IS.
TO PROVIDE THEM THE MOST
ACCURATE RECORD POSSIBLE I ALSO
PROVIDE REAL TIME FOR MY JUDGE
EVERY DAY.
YES JUDGE IN MY LAST FAMILY
LOCKER ROOM EVERY DAY AND I CAN
ASSURE YOU THEY READ IT EVERY
DAY.
I ALSO PRIDE PROVIDE ACCURATE
TRANSCRIPTS FOR THE COURTS OF
APPEAL TIMELY AND ACCURATE I
CANNOT TELL YOU HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS FOR COURT REPORTERS TO BE IN
THE COURTROOM.
I WOULD HOPE THAT SOMEDAY WE CAN
BRING BACK COURT REPORTERS TO
ALL CIVIL COURT ROOMS AS WELL.
BY HAND.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU WANNA CALL ROLL OVER QUICKLY
SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WEBER HERE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
CONTINUE.
EITHER -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ANDREW ADAMS FOR CONTRA COSTA
SPEAR COURT ANA A COURT CLERK IN
THE CRIMINAL CLERK'S OFFICE.
I'M ALSO WITH ASKED ME -- TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED EVERY YEAR -- THE
THE SENATE AN AXE NEW BILLS --
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
WHICH IS REALLY GOOD FOR THE
COMMUNITY EVERYONE ELSE BUT
IMPACTS THE CLERK'S OFFICE
IMMENSELY.
HI CREATES MORE WORK EVERY
SINGLE YEAR JUST AS LAST YEAR
IT'S SB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
IT'S A PETITION FOR RE
SENTENCING.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT BE AN
ACCESSORY ON MURDER CASES.
OUT NOBODY REALLY SAW.
OR COULD ESTIMATE HOW MUCH THAT
WAS GOING TO AFFECT US.
MY OWN SUPERVISOR MYSELF AND
BASE THEIR ENTIRE DAY MANAGING
THOSE CASELOADS MAKING SURE THEY
GET TO THE JUDGES MAKING SURE
THEY GET -- TO OUR JUSTICE
PARTNERS TO MAKE SURE THE PERSON
AS FAIR REPRESENTATION -- THIS
LIMITS OUR TIME TO WORK ON MANY
OTHER THINGS LIKE BEAUTICIANS
FOR DISMISSAL WHICH WHEN SOMEONE
IN THE COMMITTEE IS TRYING TO
CHANGE THEIR LIFE.
AND GET BACK ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
A PROCESS THAT WOULD TAKE TWO
MONTHS IS NOW TAKING WHERE IN
FROM.
SIX TO EIGHT WE JUST REALLY MORE
FUNDING FOR MORE CLERKS FEEL THE
PROVIDE ACCESS TO ALL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND HER
PEOPLE MY NAME IS TERRENCE TRACY
AND I'M ALSO A CLERK AT THE
COUNTER ACOSTA SUPERIOR COURT
WITH ASKED ME TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED IN COALITION WITH THE
SEIU -- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
WANTED TO SHARE WAS -- I'M KIND
OF THE NUMBERS GUY ON OUR TEAM.
AND TOOK JUST TO I KNOW
INFLATION IS GONE ON EVERYWHERE
AND COST OF LIVING IS GONE OUT --
I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO THE BAY AREA
WHERE I LIVE WHERE IT'S GONE UP
25% SINCE WE GOT A REYES AND
THANK GOD YOU CAME THROUGH WITH
THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION. FOR
FOR THE OF DISCRETIONARY FUNDS
FOR SO WE WERE ABLE TO GET A YOU
KNOW AND 4% OVER TO YOUR ANNA
MARIE'S.
WHICH ONCE WE GET TO THROUGH
THOSE TWO YEARS WERE BACK AT 25%
BEHIND COST OF LIVING.
I'M JUST.
THROWING THE NUMBERS OUT OF
THERE AT YOU JUST SO YOU
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHERE WE'RE
COMING FROM WE'RE NOT GREEDY
WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR MORE THAN
WHAT WE NEED WE'RE LOOKING FOR
JUST WHAT WE NEED -- TO SURVIVE
MANY -- EMPLOYEES HAVE MOVED
BACK WITH THEIR PARENTS BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD APARTMENTS --
IN OUR COMMUNITY -- A COUPLE
THINGS THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS -- YOU
KNOW DECADE OR SO IS.
DONE AWAY WITH THE RESERVE FUNDS --
BUT THE COURTS WERE ONLY ALLOWED
1% WE WERE I WOULD ASK THAT THAT
AND BE ELIMINATED THAT THE
COURTS CAN THEN DO.
I'M ADDITIONAL BUSINESS WITH
THEIR RESERVES AND ALSO.
THAT FACT THAT.
THE ME CHECK MY NOTES REAL
QUICKLY -- THERE USED TO BE A A
COST OF LIVING INCREASE LINE
ITEM ON THE BUDGET.
THAT NO LONGER EXISTS FOR COURTS --
AND THAT WE USED TO GET FUNDING
FOR A COLA THAT WE NO LONGER GET.
I'M WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
REENACTED -- I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ARE NOT YOUR
HERNANDEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTER
ASSOCIATION FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO THANK.
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE DIRECTIVE TO
ALLOCATE MONEY FOR FAMILY LAW --
COURT REPORTERS AND THAT WAS
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED -- WAS VERY
HELPFUL AND WE HOPE THAT THAT --
THAT THERE IT IS.
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL FOLLOW UP AS
TO WHERE THAT MONEY WAS SPENT
KIND OF REALLY DRILL DOWN ON
THAT HOPEFULLY WILL ALLOCATE
ADDITIONAL MONEY.
LET ME ADD A COUPLE OF THINGS
WE'RE FINDING AND SOME OF THE
COURTS.
IS THAT THE LANGUAGE THAT SAID
THAT THE MONEY WOULD BE USED TO
SUPPLEMENT AND NOT SUPPLANT.
ENCORE REPORTERS IN FAMILY LAW I
WAS KIND OF RED LOW BUT NARROWLY
THESE WERE HER ON THE GROUND AND
THAT IS TO SUPPLEMENT -- FOR
FAMILY LAW CASES AND SO WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN SOME QUARTERS KIND
OF A SHIFTING AROUND THEY MAY.
THEY MAY ADD COURT REPORTERS AND
PAY FOR IT -- CORPORATE OF HIM
ON PAY FOR OUT OF THE THE
DISCRETIONARY MONEY.
BUT THOSE COURT REPORTERS WERE
IN HANDLING OTHER CASES SO THEY
THEY DIDN'T.
SUPPLANT FAMILY LAW CORD PORTERS
BUT THE SUPPLANTED HARPER'S
OVERALL SO I THINK NEED TO BE
CLEAR THAT THE DIRECTIVE IS.
TO SUPPLEMENT THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF COURT REPORTERS IN THE
COURTHOUSE AS OPPOSED TO JUST
SUPPLEMENT THE NUMBER OF COURT
PERSONALLY FAMILY LAW.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING TO LOOK AT
GOING FORWARD.
THE OTHER THING TO LOOK AT GOING
FORWARD IS WHY YOU EVEN HAVE TO
ASK FOR ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR
FAMILY LAW.
KEEP IN MIND YOU SHOULD LOOK AT
HOW.
MONEY IS ALLOCATED RIGHT NOW
THAT SUPPOSED TO BE THERE FOR
COURT REPORTERS EVERY TIME
THERE'S A JUDICIAL SLOT THERE'S
MONEY THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
PROVIDED. FOR STAFF FOR MONEY IS
PROVIDED FOR STAFF TO SUPPORT
THE JUDICIAL POSITION.
WHAT WE'RE FINDING THAT THEN YOU
WOULD EXPECT THAT THE RECORD
QUARTER FOR EVERY JUDGE --
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT THE
CASE IN FACTIF YOU WALK SIX
BLOCKS FROM HERE.
THE COURT REPORTERS HAVE BEEN
YOU KNOW SCRAMBLING BECAUSE
THERE ARE COURT ROOMS THAT ARE
CLOSED EVERY DAY.
HALF A DAY SOMETIMES A FULL DAY.
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO COURT
REPORTERS FOR THOSE COURT ROOMS.
SO THAT'S A PROBLEM THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF REVENUE STREAMS
ALREADY IN PLACE TO ENSURE THEIR
CORE PORTS AVAILABLE BUT PART OF
THE REASON WHY YOU HAVE TO ADD
MONEY IS BECAUSE THERE'S SOME
QUESTIONS OF HOW WE'RE MANAGING
THE MONEY NOW -- LET ME JUST.
COMING UP VERY QUICKLY I WILL
SUMMON UP THAT AS YOU ALSO LOOK
AT THIS KEEP IN MIND THAT COURT
REPORTERS ARE THERE TRYING TO
HIRE THEM.
THEIR PAY THEIR TRANSFER FEES
COVER THEIR COSTS FOR THE WORK
IN THE EVENINGS AND WEEKENDS SET
BY STATUTE. THIRTY YEARS AGO
THOSE ARE TRYING TO HIRE NEW
COURT REPORTERS AND WE LET THEM
KNOW -- BY THE WAY HAVE TO WORK
ON WEEKENDS IN THE EVENINGS AND
IF YOU'RE BEHIND YOUR LATE.
THE TRANSCRIPT FEE THAT YOU CAN
CHARGE IT CUTS IN HALF BY
STATUTE IN IT HASN'T BEEN REYES
SINCE NINETEEN NINET THAT NEEDS
TO BE CHANGED AS WELL THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR A COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TIM STEED ASSISTANT GENERAL
MANAGER AT THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION PROBABLY
REPRESENTING ELEVEN HUNDRED PLUS
FRONTLINE WORKERS WORK FOR THE
ORANGE COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT.
OFTEN WHENEVER WE THINK ABOUT
THE ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE IN
OUR MINDS WE THINK OF JUDGES IN
BLACK ROBES JUDGE.
ATTORNEYS ARGUED FOR THEIR
CLIENT BUT OFTEN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE
HAPPENS IN MUCH LESS GLAMOROUS
BUT NO MUCH BUT MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT SPACES DONE BY PUBLIC
SERVANTS.
THESE PUBLIC SERVANTS HAVE TAKEN
AN OATH TO TAKE ON THE MORAL AND
ETHICAL MISSION OF THE
GOVERNMENT TO PROTECT AND
EMPOWER EVERYONE EQUALLY.
THERE IS NO APPLICATION FOR THAT
THERE ISN'T TECHNOLOGY FOR THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE
WILL AND ALWAYS WILL BE.
PEOPLE HELPING PEOPLE SO THE
BEST USE AND WE DO APPRECIATE
THE LAST YEAR'S ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO THE SUPERIOR COURT
WE'RE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WITH THE GOVERNOR IS
CURRENT RECOMMENDATION WE HOPE
THE COMMITTEE CAN ALSO MAKE SURE
THAT WE INCLUDE.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT GOES TO
THE LOCAL SUPERIOR COURT SYSTEM
SO THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
CHARGE WITH THE MISSION OF
GOVERNMENT ARE ABLE TO EXECUTE
THAT MISSION THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TREES APPLE ARE I
AM.
OF AN EMPLOYEE WITH THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT I'VE BEEN
THERE FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS COREY
PORTER.
AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF SEIU
LOCAL -- TEN TO ONE I'M JUST
HERE TO SAY THAT FAMILY LAW
REPORTERS ARE NECESSARY TO
ENFORCE THE JUDGE'S ORDERS BY.
PRESERVING AN ADEQUATE RECORD
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF LIVES OF THE WHOLE FAMILY
ESPECIALLY THE CHILDREN.
IN ORDER TO HAVE A COMPETENT
RECORD I AM TALKING ABOUT A
RECORD REPORTED BY A COURT
REPORTER NOT ELECTRONIC WE
RECORDING.
THIS HAS BEEN PROVEN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
THIS IS THE ONLY WAY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC WE ARE ONLY ASKING
THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THAT FAMILY
MATTERS ARE JUST AS CRUCIAL AND
ARE JUST AS IMPORTANT.
AS THE AS THE MOST HEINOUS OF
CRIMINAL MATTERS DO NOT DENY
EQUAL JUSTICE TO THE PUBLIC WE
ARE ASKING.
YOU TO RESPECT THE PUBLIC BY
RESPECTING SUPPORT WORKERS.
BY PROVIDING FAMILY LAW
REPORTERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HEARING ME.
HI THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME FOR HEARING MY NAME IS
APRIL HAVE ROW AND I WORK FOR
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT I'M A COURT REPORTER --
CORPORATE IS PROVIDE INVALUABLE
SERVICE TO OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM
MAINTAIN NOT ONLY THE RECORD BUT
THE SANCTITY OF COURT
PROCEEDINGS.
THIS IS A FEMALE DOMINATED
PROFESSION ESPECIALLY DURING
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH WE MUST
REMIND OURSELVES THAT WE MUST
CLOSE THE PAY GAP.
IT HAS BEEN. THIRTY YEARS SINCE
WE HAVE RECEIVED AN INCREASE.
IN THE TRANSCRIPT RATE.
I'M I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
ONGOING QUESTION THE PROBABLY
MOST PEOPLE HAVE WHY CAN'T WE
JUST BE REPLACED WITH ELECTRONIC
RECORDING AS HAS BEEN TRIED.
FOR AT LEAST THIRTY YEARS WHEN I
WENT TO COURT BRING SCHOOL.
ONLY A PERSON CAN DISTINGUISH
WHAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ISSUES ARE
HIS SHOES I CAN -- THAT SPEAKING
ABOUT SHOES OUT OF MY ISSUES OR
I'MGONNA KISS THE SKY RENDON
KISS THIS GUY I COULD SAY ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT THE SKY I CAN
STOP THEM.
I WANT.
I CAN ASK THEM TO PLEASE NOT
CRUMBLE EXCUSE ME I DIDN'T HEAR
THAT OR SOMEONE SLAMS THE DOOR
SOMEONE COUGHS.
I'M A PERSON I CAN STOP AND SAY
OH I DIDN'T GET THAT.
EVERYONE WHO HAS A CASE GO TO
GOING TO COURT WANTS.
AN ACCURATE TRANSCRIPT THAT'S
WHAT I CAN PROVIDE TO THE BEST
OF MY ABILITY MUCH BETTER THAN
ANY ELECTRONIC RECORDING THAT'S
WHAT EVERYONE WANTS THAT'S WHAT
WE CAN DO RIGHT THAT'S WHY WE
CANNOT BE REPLACED.
AND ALL WE'RE ASKING IS THAT WE
ARE.
THAT WE'RE SHOWING THAT WHAT WE
DO IS APPRECIATED AND OF THAT
OUR PAY BECOME ANSWER
COMMENSURATE WITH -- THE A WORD
I'M LOOKING.
FOR WELL THAT IS JUST CANCER
WITH INFLATION WE LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS YANDLE I AM
THE FIELD REPRESENTATIVE FOR
CONTRA COSTA COURT REPORTERS --
I AM A FIELD REPRESENTATIVE
STAFF OF SEIU TEN TO ONE AND I
WANT TO CHIME IN MY WHAT MY
BROTHER TIM WAS SAYING WHEN YOU
TURN ON THE TV AND YOU WATCH LAW
AND ORDER THE FIRST THING TO
PUBLIC.
THEIR PERCEPTION IS THAT WHEN
YOU GO INTO A COURT IT IS ABOUT
THE JUDGE AND THE DEPUTIES.
BUT AS A FIELD REPRESENTATIVE IN
THE WORK THAT I DO TO REPRESENT
WORKERS WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THE WHOLE PICTURE THE WHOLE
SYSTEM WE HAVE SO.
THE FOLKS WHO DO WITH THE
SERVICE SERVICE WORKERS WE HAVE
COURT REPORTERS WE HAVE CLERKS
WE HAVE ALL THE FOLKS THAT WE
TEND TO FORGET ABOUT.
WITHOUT THEM.
THE SYSTEM WOULD BREAK DOWN WE
NEED COURT REPORTERS WE NEED THE
COURTS TO DO THEIR WORK -- AND
WHAT WE'RE NEEDING IN ASKING YOU
IS NOT TO FORGET ABOUT THEM
ISN'T IS THERE JUST AS VALUABLE
IN A COURT ROOM BECAUSE THEY TOO
ARE THE FACES OF JUSTICE.
SO WAS BY A FIELD REPRESENTATIVE
I'M ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT THE
COURTS FINANCIALLY TO KEEP THEM.
UP AND RUNNING AND YOU KNOW SO
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO FOR OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR WEBER IN
OTHER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KASHA CLARK I AM A COURTROOM
CLERK FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT.
AS WELL AS THE ALAMEDA COUNTY --
CHAPTER PRESIDENT FOR NC I YOU
I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THE MY
FELLOW -- COURT ROOM A COURT
REPORTERS IN ACTS ASKING.
TO SUPPORT THEM IN.
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DISCRETIONARY
FUNDS TO THE COURT.
TO ALLOW EQUAL ACCESS. TO
JUSTICE FOR EVERYONE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MAYA
WALKER I'M A CIVIL COURTROOM
CLERK FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT AND WE DON'T HAVE
COURT REPORTERSIN OUR
COURTROOMS AND WE NEED THEM VERY
BAD.
SO I'M HERE TO ASK FOR SOME
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF COURT REPORTERS IN
OUR COURT ROOM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ARE ALSO SOMEBODY
AMONG.
I'VE BEEN IT.
LABEL WASN'T AS IF YOU'RE GOING
TO COLLEGE OF WHAT IS FIFTEEN
YEARS AND I CAN TELL YOU
HONESTLY CALIFORNIA'S PART BEAD.
ONE OF THE FEW ESTATES IN THE
COLLEGE WITHOUT ACCESS TO
UNDERMINE UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
PEOPLE CLEAN OUT WHATEVER WANTS
PEOPLE COULD DO GLASS IS.
ARE AND WHAT ABOUT THE YARD
PEOPLE DO THE JOBS THAT.
WE DON'T LIKE TO DO FOR THE MOST
PART TO BE HONEST I WOULD SAY.
CALIFORNIA THE LEADING STATE
THAT PROVIDES ACCESS TO JUSTICE
FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T SEE.
SO ALL I'M ASKING IS FOR YOU
GUYS TO DO ANYTHING I GOT BEEN
DOING MORE MONEY FOR THE COURTS.
FOR THE REPORTERS CORRECT WHAT
SO EVER GEORGE'S DOESN'T MATTER
WE WORK FOR THE COURTS ACCESS
THE JOYS THIS NOT JUST FOR THE
PEOPLE WHY HERE.
BEFORE THE WITHOUT WE DON'T SEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATHY
O'CONNELL I'M HERE FROM THE
SUPERIOR COURT OF CALIFORNIA
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF COURT
REPORTER SERVICES FOR LOS
ANGELES WHERE WE PROVIDE COURT
REPORTERS IN MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY COURTROOMS.
ACROSS FORTY LOCATIONS IN THE
COUNTY -- INCLUDING ALL FAMILY
LAW COURT ROOMS I'M HAPPY TO SAY --
I'M HERE TODAY IN IN LIGHT OF
SOME INFORMATION THAT I RECEIVED
AFTER HEARING LAST WEEK -- AND I
WOULD AGREE THAT THAT COURT
REPORTERS ARE THE GOLD STANDARD
IN THE COURT ROOMS -- BUT I'M
CONCERNED THAT THERE BE MEET
MAYBE SOME CONFUSION ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE COURTS ARE
FACING -- IN REGARDS TO HIRING
COURT REPORTERS AND SO I WANT TO
COME TODAY TO SPEAK WITH YOU AND
JUST TO GIVE YOU THE FACTS ABOUT
LOS ANGELES I CAN SPEAK FOR LOS
ANGELES -- IN AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE HAVING IN COURT
REPORTER RESOURCES SO IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN I'LL GIVE
YOU THE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN NUMBERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WE
RECEIVED TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO APPLICATIONS FOR THE COURT
REPORTER POSITION FOR THE COUNTY.
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX OF
THOSE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
APPLICANTS DID NOT QUALIFY THEY
DID NOT HOLD A COURT REPORTER
LICENSE THE STATE LICENSE -- A
OR SOME OF THEM HAD CONVICTIONS
THAT DID YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
CONDUCIVE TO WORKING FOR THE
QUIRK.
OUT OF THE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY OUT OF THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO APPLICATIONS WE HAD
FIFTY SIX QUALIFIED APPLICANTS.
WE CALLED ALL FIFTY SIX FOR
INTERVIEW. TWENTY TWO DID NOT
RESPOND OR DECLINED TO INTERVIEW.
THAT LEFT US WAS THIRTY FOUR WE
MADE THIRTY FOUR JOB OFFERS FOR
THE POSITION OF COURT REPORTER
FOR THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
FOURTEEN DECLINE THE OFFER.
SO IT NETTED US. TWENTY HIRES IN
THE ENTIRE YEAR OF TWO CALENDAR
YEAR TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SO
WHERE IT MIGHT LOOK LIKE WE
RECEIVED A LOT OF APPLICATIONS
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO WE
ENDED UP WITH TWENTY HIRES FOR
THE WHOLE YEAR.
EXCUSE ME -- WE ALSO HAD THIRTY
TWO COURT REPORTERS LEAVE
SERVICE IN THE YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SO WERE
WERE UPSIDE DOWN ALREADY AND IN
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN TO
DATE SO WE'RE ABOUT AT THE END
OF THE FIRST QUARTER WE'VE
RECEIVED.
A TOTAL OF EIGHT APPLICATIONS
FROM QUALIFIED COURT REPORTERS.
AND WE'VE HAD WE'VE HIRED SIX OF
THE EIGHT AND WE'VE HAD ELEVEN
COURT REPORTERS LEAVE SERVICE SO
FAR THIS YEAR SO AGAIN WE'RE
STARTING OFF UPSIDE DOWN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OKAY.
I THINK THAT -- I'M SORRY BUT
THEN THE BACK OF THE ROOM --
MICHELLE CASTER THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION --
WE REPRESENT TRIAL COURT
EMPLOYEES AND THIRTY NINE COUNTY
STRUCK CALIFORNIA.
FIRST I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR PROVIDING -- DISCRETIONARY
FUNDS TO THE TRIAL COURT'S LAST
YEAR -- WHAT THAT ENABLED?
WHAT WAS UNIQUE ABOUT LAST YEAR
IS THAT YOU PROVIDED TO POTS OF
FUNDING SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO BE ALLOCATED TO ALL
TRIAL COURTS?
AND FORTY SEVEN MILLION FOR THE
MOST UNDER FUNDED COURTS PRIOR
TO THAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDS WERE COMING
TO THE TRIAL COURT'S WERE
ALLOCATED UNDER THE WAFFEN
METHODOLOGY SO THERE WERE.
DONOR COURTS A RECIPIENT COURTS
SO NOT ALL COURTS BENEFITTED
EQUALLY DURING THE RESTORATION
OF FUNDS OF THE LAST FEW YEARS
UNTIL LAST YEAR.
HOWEVER LAST LAST YEAR ALL
COURTS WERE ABLE TO MAKE SOME
MODEST IMPROVEMENTS AND WE'VE
SEEN SOME NICE -- UP MOMENTUM
THERE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
ADDITIONAL MOMENTUM THIS YEAR IT
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
ADDITIONAL DISCRETIONARY FUNDS
ALLOCATED TO ALL COURTS.
AND SOME FUNDS ALLOCATED TO MOST
UNDERFUNDED COURTS WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BRING THEM UP.
BUT A DISH ONLY -- TRIAL COURTS
DO NOT HAVE ANY COST OF DOING
BUSINESS ADJUSTMENTS OR A COLA
IN THE BUDGETS.
SO THEY ARE UNABLE TO PREDICT ON
YOU KNOW ANY MODEST CHANGES IN
THEIR BUDGET SO THEY CAN BUT
BUDGET OVER YEARS RATHER THAN
FROM YEAR TO YEAR -- IF THEY
HAVE MID YEAR COST INCREASES
THAT ARE ON ANTICIPATED THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY MECHANISM TO
ADDRESSES CASA BUSINESS CHANGES.
ADDITIONALLY THEY DON'T HAVE A
MECHANISM TO PREDICT -- ANY EVEN
MODEST AMOUNTS OF DOLLARS FOR
THEIR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING --
THAT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO WITH
THEIR REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES --
PRIOR TO I THINK WAS TWO
THOUSAND NINE THERE WAS A
MECHANISM IN THE TRUCK OR BUDGET
CALL THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS
LIMóN ADJUSTMENT.
ENACT AFFECT ACTED LIKE A COLA
FOR THE TRIAL COURTS AND ALONG
WITH THAT WAS -- SOME STATUTORY
LANGUAGE THE KIND OF SAID WHAT
THAT STATE APPROPRIATION LIMIT
ADJUSTMENT WAS.
FOR WE THINK IT'S TIME FOR TRIAL
COURTS TO KIND OF HAVE THAT
FORMULA COME BACK -- IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE THAT THEY'RE ONE OF
THE VERY FEW BUDGETS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT DOESN'T HAVE ANY
KIND OF COLA OR ANY KIND OF
AUTOMATIC ADJUSTMENT.
ON FOR CONCORD ANY DOING --
BUSINESS CHANGES SO WE'D LIKE TO
SEE THAT COME BACK WITH REGARD
TO COURT BORDERS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT.
CALIFORNIA LAW ONLY ALLOWS THE
TRANSCRIPT A VERBATIM RECORD CAN
ONLY BE DONE BY A CERTIFIED
SHORTHAND REPORTER.
SO NOT ONLY ARE THE THE GOLD
STANDARD THEY ARE THE STANDARD
IN CALIFORNIA IF YOU WANT A
TRANSCRIPT.
WE DO HAVE TWO SUPREME COURT
DECISIONS ONCE JAMISON BE DOSTA.
THAT SAID ALL INDIGENT LITIGANTS
ARE ENTITLED TO A A TRANSCRIPT
IN CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN THAT CAN ONLY BE DONE BY A
COURT REPORTER.
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT THERE WAS A
NOTHER DECISION.
CALLED I DO CAN BE COMANCHE
HILLS THE REMANDED DECISION BACK
TO THE TRIAL COURT BECAUSE IT
THE LITIGANT DID NOT HAVE.
A TRANSCRIPT BECAUSE THERE WAS
NO CORPS PROPER PORTER PROVIDED
TO THEM -- WE THINK THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
ALLOCATED.
THROUGH LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO BE
USED FOR COURT REPORTERS WAS A
NICE START BUT IT FALLS SHORT
FROM THE NEED THE TRIAL COURT TO
DO HALF SO WE'D LIKE TO SEE SOME
CONTINUED INVESTMENT TO BRING
BACK.
FAMILY LAW COURT REPORTERS AS
WELL AS CIVIL REPORTER SINCE ALL
INDIGENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE
INDEED INDEED LITIGANTS HAVE THE
RIGHT. TO RECEIVE A TRANSCRIPT --
ONE LAST THING JUST WANT TO SAY --
WE ALSO SUPPORT DEPENDENCY
COUNCILS WHILE SPENDING FOR
JUDGES BUT THE FUNDING FOR THOSE
JUDGES IT COMES FOR STAFF MUST
BE USED FOR STAFF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD NIGHT
ITEMS ISSUE NUMBER TWO THIS ITEM
WILL BE HELD OVER -- IN TERMS OF
ISSUE NUMBER ONE ISSUE TO ITS
PRE TRIAL SERVICE FUNDING --
WILL HAVE SOMEONE FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AARON JOHNSON
THE DIRECTOR OFFICE OF PRE TRIAL
SERVICES IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR WEBER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS LUCY FOCUS THE NINE THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF BUDGET
SERVICES AT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
THIS AGENDA ITEM IS RELATED TO A
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION ALLOCATION
OF A TWO YEAR IS. TO FROM THE
IMPLEMENTATION OPERATION
VALUATION OF PROGRAMS ALL
EFFORTS IN EIGHT TO TEN COURTS
RAGE TO PRE TROUT DECISION
MAKING.
SITTING NEXT TO ME A SHIRLEY
CURRENT SHE IS THE DIRECTOR OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SERVICES
OFFICIAL COUNCIL.
AND IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR WEBER IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
SHELLEY CURRENT I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE SERVICES AT
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
OF THE PRIEST COULD TRIAL
LANDSCAPING CALIFORNIA IS
CHANGING DRAMATICALLY I'M IS
CHANGING THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
TO AND THOSE CHANGES ARE
HAPPENING BECAUSE OF LAWSUITS
AND LEGISLATION THAT'S BEING
ADOPTED ANOTHER CHANGES THAT ARE
ARE HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IN TERMS OF LAWSUITS JUST LAST
WEEK THERE WAS A HEARING -- IN
THE NORTHERN DISTRICT OF
CALIFORNIA I'M A FEDERAL COURT
CASE THAT LOOKED AT THE USE OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO SHERIFFS USE
OF THE BELL SCHEDULE -- SHORTLY
BEFORE THAT THERE WAS A A
HEARING BEFORE OUR STATE SUPREME
COURT -- THAT LOOKED AT THE
SUPERVISION OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE RELEASED ON BAIL AND WERE
AWAITING -- TO TO BUT ARGUMENTS
TO BE HEARD BEFORE THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
HUMPHREY AND WEB THAT ALSO
ADDRESS PRE TRIAL SO THINGS ARE
REALLY HAPPENING.
ADDITIONALLY ALL OF YOU ARE
AWARE THAT THE LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR ADOPTED SB TEN THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES -- HOW PRE
TRIAL IS HANDLED IN CALIFORNIA
THAT LEGISLATION HAS BEEN PUT ON
HOLD UNTIL THE VOTERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON IT THAT
AT THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION?
AND THEN ALSO THINGS HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
THERE IS COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA HAVE ADOPTED SOME
FORM OF PRE TRIAL CHANGE SUMMER
MORE EXTENSIVE LIKE SANTA CLARA --
AS MISTER ROGERS WILL SPEAK
ABOUT AND THEN OTHERS ARE ARE
ARE SMALLER MORE INCREMENTAL
CHANGES SO THINGS ARE REALLY
HAPPENING.
WHAT THIS PILOT WOULD SUGGEST
DOING IS -- HAVING COURT
PROGRAMS IN EIGHT TO TEN COURTS --
THAT'LL BE FAR MORE EXPENSIVE IN
IN THOSE COURT RECORDS WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE HAPPENING IS IS
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE THE
COUNTIES WITH PARDON ME THE
COURT AND PROBATION -- BILL
EXIST UNDER EXISTING TO OPERATE
UNDER EXISTING LAW AS IT IS
RIGHT NOW -- RISK ASSESSMENTS
WILL BE CONDUCTED AND DECISIONS
WILL BE MADE PRE ARRANGEMENT AND
SO THAT'S KIND OF THE FRAMEWORK
THAT WILL HAPPEN.
THE GOALS OF THE PROGRAM AT
THEIR MOST BASIC LEVEL.
OUR TO FUND PRACTICES AND AND
PROGRAMS THAT WILL PROMOTE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND RETURN TO
COURT -- THAT WILL FOR SO LET'S
TAKE A QUICK DECISION MAKING --
SO THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN BE
ASSESSED QUICKLY AND IF THEY ARE
SAFE TO BE RELEASED CAN BE
RELEASED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE I THINK MANY PEOPLE ARE
WELL AWARE OF THE DETRIMENTAL
EFFECTS AFFECTS THAT INDIVIDUALS
HAVE.
WHEN THEY WERE DETAINED -- WHEN
WHEN THEY COULD BE RELEASED
SAFELY AND AND SOONER
ADDITIONALLY -- WE WANT TO
MINIMIZE BIAS IN THESE DECISION
MAKING -- AND WE WANT TO
EVALUATE THESE PROGRAMS -- IN
ORDER TO GAIN A MUCH BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WORKS --
SO THAT IT CAN BE REPLICATED AND
WHAT DOESN'T WORK SO THAT WE CAN
AVOID THOSE PRACTICES.
IN TERMS OF SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
THAT WE ANTICIPATE BEING FUNDED --
WE IMAGINE CONTRACTS BETWEEN
COURTS AND PROBATION IN ORDER TO
CONDUCT THOSE RISK ASSESSMENTS A
JUDICIAL OFFICER RELEASED PRIOR
TO RELATE ARRAIGNMENT AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE.
VALIDATION OF RISK ASSESSMENT
TOOLS RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS ARE
BEING USED THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW VERY FEW OF THOSE
TOOLS OF ACTUALLY BEEN VALIDATED
ON THEIR LOCAL POPULATIONS AND
SO PART OF THIS PROGRAM WILL
ALSO.
RESULT IN THE VALIDATION OF SOME
OF THE MAJOR TOOLS.
DATA EXCHANGES BETWEEN LOCAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM PARTNERS AGAIN SO
THAT THOSE DECISIONS CAN BE MADE
QUICKLY AND ALSO DATA EXCHANGES
BETWEEN THE COURTS AND THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AS IT RELATES
TO PRE TRIAL SO THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO EVALUATE
THESE PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE.
YOU ALL THE INFORMATION THAT IS
NECESSARY AS YOU CONTINUE TO
MAKE THESE POLICY DECISIONS AND
THEN THINGS LIKE COURT REMINDERS --
BUT I I THINK IT IS THAT IT'S
EVIDENT THAT COURT REMINDERS
WORK -- IN THE SAME WAY THAT
RESTAURANT REMINDERS WORK OR
HAIR CUT REMINDERS WORK COURT
REMINDERS WORK AND SO REALLY
ENHANCING SOME OF THOSE
REMINDERS.
IN TERMSOF HOW THE COURTS WILL
BE SELECTED.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE VERY RECENTLY
APPOINTED A GROUP -- MADE UP OF
JUSTICES AND JUDGES AND COURT
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS ONE OF THE
CHARGES OF THAT GROUP IS TO
CONSIDER THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL AND TO
COME UP WITH RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THE COUNCIL TO CONSIDER --
SHOULD THIS BE INCLUDED IN THE
FINAL BUDGET -- THAT WOULD THAT
WORK GROUP HAS ALREADY STARTED
ITS WORK IN ANTICIPATION OF THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THIS MIGHT BE
INCLUDED RECOGNIZING THAT YOU
ALL WILL WENT ALONG WITH THE
GOVERNOR WILL WILL BE MAKING
THAT ULTIMATE DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT WILL BE INCLUDED
AND WHAT THE EXACT.
PARAMETERS WILL BE BUT IT JUST
IN ANTICIPATION OF TRYING TO GET
THE FUNDS OUT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE THAT GROUP HAS BEGUN
WORK -- THAT'LL BE EIGHT TO TEN
COURTS ARE GOING TO LOOK AT A
DIVERSITY OF COURTS IN TERMS OF
COURT SIZE AND LOCATION NORTHERN
SOUTHERN CENTRAL -- COASTAL WE
WANT TO LOOK AT A VARIETY OF
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS COURT
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS SO THAT
TOOLS THAT WE LEARNED OF AND AT
THAT WE DEVELOP CAN BE
REPLICATED QUICKLY AND OTHER --
IN OTHER COUNT IN OTHER COURTS
SO AS PRE TRIAL CHANGES WILL BE
ABLE TO ADOPT THOSE PRACTICES
QUICKLY AND OTHER AND THEN THE
SAME IN TERMS OF RISK ASSESSMENT
TOOLS ON RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN THE
MARKETPLACE ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE A VARIETY OF THOSE TOOLS
THAT.
ARE REPRESENTED ALSO -- I
ANTICIPATE THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO LOOK AT THINGS LIKE
STRONG LOCAL COLLABORATION --
HISTORY OF SUCCESSFULLY MEETING --
A GRANT REQUIREMENTS ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT THE THE PILOT SOON
AFTER ITS ADOPTED RIGHT NOW THE
THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
ANTICIPATES A TWO YEAR PROGRAM
AND SO GETTING UP AND RUNNING AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND ALSO THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
THE DATA THAT'S NECESSARY TO
MEET THE OBJECTIVES TO MEASURE
THE OBJECTIVES OF OF THE TOOL
QUICKLY I'LL MENTION THE
EVALUATION PLAN -- WE ANTICIPATE --
BEING ABLE TO COLLECT WE'RE
COLLECTING THE DATA THAT'LL BE
NECESSARY TO ASSESS EACH OF THE
VALIDATED TOOLS -- USING THE
PILOTS IN ORDER TO MEASURE ANY
POTENTIAL BIAS -- TO DETERMINE --
IF THE PRE TRIAL PROJECT PRIDE A
A PROJECTS REDUCE PRE TRIAL
DETENTION -- DETERMINE IF THE
PRE TRIAL PILOT PROJECTS REDUCE
FAILED TO APPEAR AND ALSO TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY TO ENSURE
THAT THAT HAPPENS ALSO WE HOPE
TO WORK WITH THE PANEL OF OF
ACADEMICS -- IN ORDER TO HELP US --
WORK ON THAT DESIGN METHODOLOGY
IN ORDER TO TO INSURE THAT WE
MEET THE OBJECTIVES THAT ARE.
THAT ARE NEEDED AND SO WITH THAT
I WILL JUST SUM UP BY SAYING --
WE ARE APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S SUPPORT OF OF
THIS POSSIBILITY OF OF WORKING --
IN THE COURTS AND AN ORDER TO DO
A MUCH DEEPER DIVE SO THAT THE
DAY THAT PRE TRIAL REFORM DOES
COME ALONG IN CALIFORNIA AND
AGAIN WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S
GOING TO LOOK LIKE BEAUSE OF
ALL THE DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT
ARE OUT THERE RIGHT NOW.
BUT THAT WE ARE PREPARED IN
ORDER TO RESPOND QUICKLY.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR URBAN
PANEL MY NAME IS AARON JOHNSON
IN THE CURRENT DIRECTOR FOR PRE
TRIAL SERVICES IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY.
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PRE
TRIAL SERVICES BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AS WELL AS AN
EDUCATIONAL COMMITTEE MEMBER FOR
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR PRE
TRIAL SITUATIONS.
US PATROL SERVICE AGENCIES.
I'VE BEEN A PREACHER A
PRACTITIONER FOR THE LAST ELEVEN
YEARS AND AN ADVOCATE OF PRE
TRIAL FORM IN KANSAS CALIFORNIA
AND NATIONWIDE.
HAVING SAID THIS I'M HERE TO
PROVIDE -- ONLY MY INDIVIDUAL
PRE TRIAL PRACTITIONERS POINT OF
VIEW -- BUT FOR FAR TOO LONG
CALIFORNIA JAILS HAVE BEEN
INAPPROPRIATELY HOLDING
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE LOWER RISK
TO THE COMMUNITY.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
ARBITRARY AMOUNTS OF MONEY FOR
BAIL.
THIS IS ALSO LET THE
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNTS OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR TO BE HELD AS
WELL AND CREATED A TWO TIERD
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE. ONE FOR THOSE
WITH MEANS AND ONES FOR THOSE
WITHOUT.
THIS SWELLING OF THE PRE TRIAL
POPULATION IS ALSO COSTING
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS IN THE FORM
OF OVER USE OF THE MOST -- COST
IN IN HUMANE OF RESOURCES IN THE
FORM OF OUR JAIL BED SPACE.
IN REVIEWING THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE OF SENATE BILL SEVENTY
THREE SPECIFICALLY THE SECTION I
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS
TO MAKING FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR
THE CHANGES OCCURRING IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRE TRIAL PROCESS.
HOWEVER HAVE A FEW ISSUES WITH
THE CURRENT WORDING OF THE STATE
OF THIS SECTION AND HOW AGENCIES
WOULD BE ABLE TO RECEIVE THIS
FUNDING.
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS THE
LABELING OF THIS FUNDING FOR
PILOT SITES THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PRE TRIAL
SERVICES RECOGNIZES THESE
EFFORTS IN A BEEN OCCURRING FOR
OVER FIFTY YEARS IN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES.
AND CURRENTLY THERE FORTY SIX
COUNTIES PROVIDING SOME LEVEL OF
PRE TRIAL SERVICES AS A STATED
EARLIER -- BUT THAT INFORMATION --
IT BASICALLY COMES FROM A REPORT
THAT IS THREE YEARS OLD WE'D
LIKE -- TO WE'D LIKE TO GET THIS
INFORMATION UPDATED SO WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT'S OCCURRING -- IN
THE PRE TRIAL SERVICES AGENCIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
I FEEL THIS IS A MISSTEP IN
ALLOCATION IS A PILOT PROGRAMS
ARE NOT NEEDED IN CALIFORNIA --
THERE BEEN CONTINUING LIKE I
SAID AGENCIES DOING THIS WORK
FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME.
THE CONTINUED FUNDING OF ONGOING
EFFORTS ARE.
BY CONTRAST SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS COULD FUND FIFTY ONE OF
THE FIFTY LOWER POPULATED
COUNTIES WITH A SIMILAR PREACHER
SYSTEM AS SUCH AND SENT A CLEAR
AT THIS TIME.
SECOND THE LANGUAGE FOLLOW
SIMILAR FUNDING STRATEGIES
DESCRIBED IN SENATE BILL TEN
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THE REFERENDUM
PASSED IN THE SENATE BILL TEN IS
NOW ON THE BALLOT.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY HOWEVER AS
ALSO STATED RECENT LITIGATION
WITH THE HUMPHRIES BUFF AND WEB
DECISIONS.
CONTINUE TO DRIVE THE NEED FOR
THE COUNTIES TO RECEIVE ON GOING
SUPPORT IS THESE DECISIONS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CHANGE OUR PRE
TRIAL IS ADMINISTERED OVERNIGHT
VERSES WAITING FOR BALLOT.
OR REFERENDUM INITIATIVE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY AS STATED BEFORE
THERE ARE MANY COUNTIES WHO
ALREADY HAVE SUCCESSFUL PRE
TRIAL PROGRAMS IN PLACE IN THIS
FUNDING WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE
TO SUPPORT.
ALL SUCH PROGRAMMING -- IF LATE
LIMITED TO JUST COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS.
THIS DOES NOT FOLLOW THE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE CREATED AND
SENATE BILL TEN AS THERE IS
NOTHING INDICATING COURTS MUST
CONTRACT WITH PROBATION ONLY
THAT THE COURT MAY NOT CONTRACT
WITH A QUALIFIED AGENCY THAT HAS
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY. FOR
MAKING ARRESTED TO TENSIONS
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION.
THIRD AND MOST IMPORTANT THE PRE
TRIAL PROCESS IS NOT THE SAME AS
POST ADJUDICATION PROBATION THE
PRE TRIAL FOCUSES ABOUT WORKING
WITH CLIENTS TO MAKE SURE THEY
SHOW UP FOR COURT.
AND ARE NOT A DANGER IN THE
COMMUNITY.
PRE TRIAL PROFESSIONALS HAVE A
SENSE OF RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS HOLDING THE
INDIVIDUAL ACCOUNTABLE AND ARE
HELD TO A SIMILAR BUT DIFFERENT
STANDARDS LIKE PROBATION BASED
ON THE LONG NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE.
THE AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION AND
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF PRE
TRIAL SERVICES ARE PROVIDED.
WE SERVE A DIFFERENT PURPOSE AND
DEALING WITH SIMILAR BUT
DISTINCTLY DIFFERENT POPULATIONS
AS OUR CLIENTS HAVE NOT BEEN
CONVICTED OF ANY LAW VIOLATION.
THE SIMILARITIES AND DIFFERENCES
ARE DISTINCTLY REVIEWED INTENSE
NOT HE'S TWENTY EIGHTEEN
RESEARCH PUBLICATION PRE TRIAL
RELEASE ON PROBATION WHAT IS THE
SAME AND WHAT IS DIFFERENT.
IF THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
HAVE NOT REVIEWED THIS MATERIAL
I WOULD STRONGLY SUGGEST THEY
BECOME FAMILIAR WITH THE
INFORMATIVE AND FUNDAMENTAL LOOK
AT THE TWO DIFFERENT PROCESSES.
PRIMARILY PREACHER RELEASE
SHOULD NEVER BE CONFUSED WITH A
RECOGNIZED FORM OF PUNISHMENT.
ONLY SERVING TO ENSURE THE
CLIENT RETURNS TO COURT AND IS
NOT A DANGER TO THE COMMUNITY.
LASTLY I HAVE NO DOUBT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WILL BE
UTILIZING THE FUNDING ALLOCATED
TO THEM. TO BE ABLE TO OVERSEE
THE PRE TRIAL REFORM EFFORTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S NOT A DESIGNATED
INDIVIDUAL OR GROUP THAT I WAS
AWARE OF AT THIS TIME.
WHO WILL OVERSEE THIS AND
PROVIDE A PLAN ON HOW THE COURTS
IN PRE TRIAL AGENCIES WILL
COMMUNICATE THE RESULTS TO THIS
UNDER UNIDENTIFIED GROUP FOR
COMPILATION A REVIEW?
I WOULD SUGGEST PARTNERING WITH
AN INDEPENDENT AGENCY LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PRE
TRIAL SERVICES AS MUCH OF THE
RESEARCH IDENTIFIED IN THIS BILL
HAS ALREADY BEEN COMPLETED BY
MULTIPLE AGENCIES IN THE STATE
THEY'RE JUST NEEDS TO BE A
COORDINATED EFFORT TO GATHER AND
DISSEMINATE THE INFORMATION ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED.
IN CONCLUSION THERE ARE MANY
COUNTIES ARE ALREADY PROVIDING
THE SERVICES THIS BILL INTENDS
TO PILOT WITH THE MONEY SET
ASIDE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
DRAFTERS OF THE BILL IT --
TALKING CONSULT WITH THE LEAD
AGENCIES ALREADY PROVIDING THE
SERVICES TO ALLOCATE THIS
FUNDING TO PROMOTE THE EXPANSION
OF SERVICES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND DESIGNATE A
SPECIFIC PERSON AS A POINT OF
CONTACT FOR THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
IN MOVING THE LEGAL AND
MEANINGFUL PRE TRIAL REFORM IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM DEPARTMENT
FINANCE [inaudible]
OKAY HELLO.
I NEED ONLY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- WHILE IT IS
CERTAINLY POSSIBLE THAT THE
PROPOSED PROGRAM COULD BE
WORTHWHILE.
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT
THE LACK OF DETAIL MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
EFFECTIVELY EVALUATE IT AND
WEIGHED AGAINST ITS OTHER
GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES IT'S NOT
AN INSIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
SO BECAUSE OF THIS WE DO --
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT TO THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH. TO SUBMIT A
MORE WELL DEVELOPED PROPOSAL BY
APRIL FOR THE FIFTEENTH FOR
CONSIDERATION AS PART OF THE
SPRING BUDGET HEARINGS
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
YEAH.
OF AND SPECIFICALLY THE PROPOSAL
SHOULD INCLUDE INFORMATION IN
FOUR KEY AREAS -- SOME OF THEM
WERE TOUCHED ON IN MISS CURRENTS --
TESTIMONY BUT I THINK WE WOULD
NEED ADDITIONAL DETAIL THE FIRST
AREA IS WHAT ARE THE PRIMARY
GOALS OF THE PROGRAM AND THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRAM IS STRUCTURED
IN A MANNER.
CAPABLE OF ACHIEVING THOSE GOALS.
THE SECOND AREA -- IS WHAT TYPE
OF PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES WOULD
BE SUPPORTED AND DO THEY MEET
THOSE PROBLEM THOSE GOALS THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED.
THE THIRD AREA IS HOW ALL THE
FUNDING BE ALLOCATED TO ENSURE
THAT IT'S BEING DONE IN A FAIR
MANNER.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
WOULD KNOW IS UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL MOST
OF THE DECISIONS ARE CURRENTLY
LAUGHS TO THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
WHICH MEANS THAT.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE LITTLE
EMPLOY.
IN WHETHER THE FUNDS ARE USED
CONSISTENT WITH THEIR PRIORITIES.
AND THE FOURTH AND FINAL AREA IS
ACTUALLY THIS ISSUE ABOUT
EVALUATION -- AND SPECIFICALLY
THERE SHOULD BE DETAILS ON HOW
THE FUNDED PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES WILL BE EVALUATED IN
A WAY THAT CAN INFORM STATEWIDE
DECISION MAKING.
AND SO CUMULATIVELY ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION IS NECESSARY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO EFFECTIVELY
EVALUATE THE PROGRAM.
AND DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT IT
IS STRUCTURED OPERATED AND
FUNDED IN A WAY THAT MEETS
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES IS
CAPABLE OF ACHIEVING LEGISLATIVE
EXPECTATIONS.
AND THAT THE FUNDING IS USED IN
AN ACCOUNTABLE MANNER.
SO WE ARE WITHHOLDING
RECOMMENDATION PENDING THE
SUBMISSION OF THIS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE INFORMATION IS NOT PROVIDED
WE DO RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL.
ANY COMMENTS.
YES PLEASE DON'T.
THANK YOU AT ABSOLUTELY THINK
THAT THAT WE NEED TO HAVE THE
BUDGET ALLOCATION HERE AND
CONTINUE TO THE WORK THAT WE
STARTED WITH WITH SB TEN BUT I I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE.
BOTH FOR JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND
THE ADMINISTRATION.
THAT WHAT WE WHAT I THINK WE
NEED TO BE DOING AND IT IS A
LITTLE HARD TO KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF DETAIL BUT I THINK
THERE'S A LOT THAT NEEDS TO BE
FLESHED OUT.
WE HAVE EXISTING AS WAS POINTED
OUT APPROPRIATELY THERE THERE
ARE.
A CERTAIN LEVEL OF RISK
ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE ALREADY
BEING USED AND I THINK THAT
PROVIDES IS A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
BASIS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT MAY OR
MAY BE WORKING ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
BUT ONE OF THE PIECES THAT WAS
NEGOTIATED OUT ON AT THE REQUEST
OF THE ADMINISTRATION
UNFORTUNATELY WAS DATA
COLLECTION AND UNFORTUNATELY WE
AGREED TO REMOVE DATA COLLECTION
SO EVEN IF SB.
TEN HAD MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT THE
THAT ABOUT MEASURE PUTTING IT IN
ADVANCE.
WE WERE NOT SET UP TO GET THE
DATA COLLECTION THAT WE NEED AND
NOT JUST ABOUT RISK OF FLIGHT
AND SOME OF THOSE PIECES BUT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE.
THAT AS WE PUT THESE PROGRAMS
TOGETHER AND I THINK WE CAN USE.
SOME OF THE EXISTING PROGRAMS TO
TEST AGAINST THE BIAS THAT THEY
REPRESENT.
MEETING WHO'S BEING ALLOWED.
TO TO LEAVE WHO'S NOT BEING
ALLOWED TO LEAVE BASED ON COLOR
RACE CRIMES POVERTY.
ANY OF THOSE INDICATORS.
THE PRE TRIAL.
THE BAIL SYSTEM CASH MONEY BAIL
SYSTEM HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON THE THE POOREST OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO CAN'T AFFORD
BEAR.
WITH IT AND ABSOLUTELY.
WRONG HEADED WAY FOR US TO
ENSURE PUBLIC SAFETY AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE HOLDING PEOPLE
APPROPRIATELY ACCOUNTABLE.
AND WE HAVE ENOUGH EXAMPLES I
THINK ACROSS CALIFORNIA BE ABLE
LEVERAGE OFF OF SOME OF THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT'S WHAT I THINK
THAT MONEY SHOULD BE USED. FOR
TO LOOK AT THOSE PROGRAMS AND
SET UP A STRONGER SYSTEM OF DATA
COLLECTION. TO LOOK AT WHO'S.
WHO IS BEING DETAINED UNDER THIS
RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS WHO'S NOT
TO VALIDATE THE RISK ASSESSMENT
TOOLS?
PILOT PROGRAMS MAYBE WE CAN USE
THE AS IS QUITE HAVE THE EXIT
EXISTING PROGRAMS AS THE
EXISTING PILOT PROGRAM BUT THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO SET
OURSELVES UP FOR SUCCESS.
ONCE ASSUMING.
THAT BALLOT MEASURE FAILS AND
WE'RE ALLOWED TO MOVE FORWARD ON
ON PROP.
TEN A WHAT THAT WORLD LOOKS LIKE
BUT EVEN STILL I THINK WE CAN BE
AS A STATE MAKE A LOT OF
PROGRESS TOWARDS.
APPROPRIATE WE LOOKING AT THE
VERSION SERVICES PRE TRIAL
SERVICE SAYS -- KEEP LOOKING AT
RISKS THAT PEOPLE REALLY
REPRESENT FOR FLIGHT OR NOT
FLIGHT BUT ONE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WAS REYES TONIGHT THAT I
AGREE WITH IS THAT IF WE ARE
CAREFUL.
WITH THE TOOLS THEY GET USE FOR
THESE RISK ASSESSMENTS.
THE COURTS COULD END UP
[inaudible]
STILL.
DETAINING REQUIRING THE TENSION
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR PEOPLE OF
POOR MEANS WITH WITHOUT REALLY
BALANCING SOME OF THE TOOLS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE AND I KNOW A LOT
OF THE COURTS HAS BEEN USING.
A RISK ASSESSMENT TO I THINK TO
SOME GREAT EFFECT IT'S OBVIOUSLY
BACKED BY CASH MONEY BAIL WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO GET
RID OF BY.
SOME OF THESE THESE DATA EXIST
SOME OF THESE TOOLS ARE ABLE TO
BE ASSESSED IN A PRODUCTIVE WAY
BECAUSE THEY ARE CURRENTLY BEING
USED I THINK WE TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT.
AND THEN BE ABLE TO BETTERONCE
WE COME OUT OF THIS BALLOT
MEASURE CYCLE AND GIVEN THE
LEGISLATURE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND USUALLY COUNCIL.
THE THE TIME IN THE MEANTIME AND
SOME RESOURCES TO BE ABLE LOOK
AT THESE PROGRAMS LOOK AT THE
DATA COLLECTION ASK THE
QUESTIONS THAT THAT WE NEED.
AND REALLY DESIGNED A SYSTEM
THAT WE CAN THEN HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING ONCE THIS QUESTION IS
FINALLY SETTLED.
SOME.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY BUDGET OUT
ALLOCATION I'M EXCITED ABOUT
VERY INTERESTED IN AND I WOULD
HOPE THIS COMMITTEE I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE PROBABLY SHARES THIS.
IS I HOPE YOU ARE ALL A PART OF
THE SB.
TEN GETTING THAT THROUGH OUR
HOUSE AND THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE BUT THIS IS A REAL
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN WHAT WE
NEED TO LEARN.
FOCUS FUNDS THAT'LL BE OF BEST A
FACT SO THAT WE CAN.
CONTINUE TO PUT POLICY IN PLACE
TESTED AND ENSURE THAT WE KNOW
HOW IT'S BEING USED IN EACH
COUNTY WHO'S BENEFITING FROM IT
AND AND AND HAVE A PATH TO
DETERMINE.
THAT IT IS BEING USED TO THE
FACT THAT WE WOULD INTEND FOR
THE REASONS THAT WE GOT RID OF
CASH MONEY BATH.
SO AGREE WITH LA -- WE NEED SOME
MORE DETAIL TO THAT I HOPE THAT
YOU JUST CANCEL.
THE MYSTERIES YOU CAN WORK WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AND WE CAN FOCUS
THIS SAID THAT WITH THAT THESE
MONIES CAN BE USED TO GREAT
EFFECT.
AND REALLY SET UP TO THE SUCCESS
OF CALIFORNIA.
AFTER CASH MONEY BAIL SYSTEMS
AND THIS IS A AN IMPORTANT THING
FOR US TO BE LOOKING AT THIS
TIME.
YES MISTER YEAH GEN.
I THANK YOU AND ALSO SOMEONE I
WAS ALSO THE JOINT AUTHORS SB --
TENNIS THIS IS VERY THIS
LEGISLATION IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THAT WERE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT.
AND I SAY THAT IN IN.
IN THE BACKDROP OF A MANY OF US
NOW HAVE TWELVE YEARS INSTEAD OF
SIX I ONCE HAD THE HONOR OF
SITTING.
WHERE DOCTOR WEBER WAS SITTING
IN MY FIRST YEAR WE ASKED ABOUT
A -- A COMPUTER SYSTEM THAT THE
A OC WAS WORKING ON I DON'T
THINK WE EVER GOT THAT COMPUTER
SYSTEM WE SPENT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON AND WHEN
I ASKED THE QUESTION -- WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE OF THE CHIEF JUSTICE
TOLD ME WITH THE CDO SEE TOLD ME
IT WAS THE PRESIDING JUDGES THE
PRESIDING JUDGES TOLD ME WITH
THE CHIEF JUSTICE AND WE'RE
GOING AROUND IN CIRCLES.
THEN EVERYBODY WAS PLAYING THE
LEGISLATURE FRAGMENT OF MONEY
THEY WERE BLAMING THE GOVERNOR.
AT THE END OF THE DAY FOR ME TO
START.
IF THIS DOESN'T GO RIGHT.
I NEED TO KNOW WHO IS ULTIMATELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING SURE THAT
THIS GETS DONE.
AND BEFORE YOU SAY YOU ARE.
JUST REMEMBER THIS.
SUCCESS HAS A MANY MANY MANY
FATHERS FAILURE HAS A WHOLE
BUNCH OF WORTH.
OKAY.
AND SO -- RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU CAN TELL ME [inaudible]
WHO ULTIMATELY?
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING.
THIS THIS NEW SYSTEM PRE TRIAL
ALL OF IT IS THE ONE CENTRALIZED.
INDIVIDUAL IS A THE CHIEF
JUSTICE.
HOPE YOU DON'T SEE ISSUE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL BECAUSE THEN
YOU JUST A CONSEQUENCE TELL ME
THEY REPORT TO THE CHIEF JUST
AND JUSTICE AND SAY THEY WORK
WITH BUT GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN.
MY HEAD'S GOING TO EXPLODE YOU
NEED THAT'S WHAT'S SO GREAT
ABOUT HAVING TWELVE YEARS.
I WOULD BE GONE RIGHT NOW.
DOCTOR WEBER WOOD BECAUSE I
RIGHT NOW.
MY COLLEAGUES TO MY LEFT WOULD
BE GOAL RIGHT NOW WE WOULDN'T
HAVE THIS INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY.
TO KNOW HOW ORGANIZATIONS WORK
WITHIN THE STATE AND HOW THINGS
DON'T GET DONE.
AND HE IS WAY FOR THE NEXT GROUP
ELECTED OFFICIAL COME IN AND YOU
JUST KIND OF KIND OF REHASH THE
SAME THING.
YOU DON'T HAVE A LUXURY ANYMORE.
AND SO MY FIRST QUESTION IS
WHO'S IN CHARGE OF THIS.
OKAY I WILL I WILL TRY THAT --
ONE SO THE WAY THAT THE THE
FUNDING IS STRUCTURED RIGHT NOW
IS THE DOLLARS WILL GO FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL APPROPRIATE
FUNDS THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WILL
MAKE THE DECISION ABOUT WHO IT
IS -- ABOUT THE COURTS THAT WILL
BE FUNDED THAT BEING SAID --
THERE WILL BE CLEAR --
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE PART OF
THE PRESUMABLY THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ONCE ONCE THE INTERESTS
OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED -- AND THEN THERE WILL
BE CONTRACTS BETWEEN -- THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THE COURTS
ARE INTER BRANCH AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN THE COUNCIL AND THE
COURTS -- TO MEET THE OBJECTIVES
FOR THE FUNDING -- THE COURTS
THE AND WILL TURN AND THEY WILL
CONTRACT WITH PROBATION IN ORDER
TO CONDUCT THE RISK ASSESSMENT
BUT ULTIMATELY THE DATA AND THE
REQUIREMENTS WILL COME FROM THE
FROM THE COURTS TO THE COUNCIL
AND THE COUNCIL WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING YOU
ALL INFORMATION ABOUT.
THE SUCCESSES AND THE FAILURES
OF THE PROGRAM.
SO NO DISRESPECT OKAY BUT I USED
TO DO THAT TOO THAT'S THAT SO.
BUREAUCRATIC MUMBO JUMBO I USED
TO THAT TOO JUST TO SPEND SPEND
AND SPEND.
IT SHOULD ONLY BE ONE PERSON IN
CHARGE.
DO YOU GAVE ME A BUREAUCRATIC
ANSWER OF HOW THE MONEY FLOWS.
BUT YOU WON'T YOU HAVEN'T TOLD
ME IF THE MONEY SPENT
INAPPROPRIATELY.
WHO'S GOING TO BE SITTING IN
THAT CHAIR TO EXPLAIN TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
WHAT WHAT WENT WRONG BUT MORE
IMPORTANT WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
DO TO FIX IT?
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT.
YOU CAN GIVE ME AN ANSWER YOU
GAVE ME HOW THE MONEY WILL FLOW
AND HOW IT SPENT.
AND AND ULTIMATELY -- MIGHT ALSO
BE THE REASON WHY WE DON'T HAVE
A FULL FLESHED OUT PLANNED YOU
ALSO TOLD ME.
THAT THE CHIEF JUSTICE WOULD PUT
TOGETHER A GROUP OF JUDGES. TO
HELP DECIDE HOW THIS SYSTEM IS
BEING DONE SO LET ME JUST
ANOTHER BODY.
OF JUDGES AND LAWYERS AND NO
DISRESPECT TO LAWYERS AND PRESS
THE COMPANY.
EXCLUDED I GOT.
HOME WITH A BUNCH OF LAWYERS --
DECIDING HOW ULTIMATELY ALL THIS
GOES COULD YOU NOT ALSO TALKING
ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT THIS IS
IMPACTING.
I WOULD HOPE YOU WOULD TALK TO
PEOPLE THAT -- HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THIS RISK ASSESSMENT SO
YOU MAKE A SYSTEM THAT WILL ALSO
BENEFIT THEM INCLUDING THE
EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE TO IMPLEMENT
THIS.
THAT THIS IS NOT JUST A TOP DOWN
KIND OF SYSTEM WHICH IS.
WHICH IS BEGINNING TO SOUND LIKE
AND SO [inaudible]
I I DEFINITELY WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD.
WITH US GIVING YOU YOU SOME KIND
OF FUNDING TO YOU CAN BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF FLUSHING ALL OF THIS
OUT.
BUT I HOPE IN IT.
YOU ULTIMATELY HAVE SOMEBODY
STEP UP AND SAY THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR IT THIS FOR GETTING THIS
DONE.
AND THAT'S USUALLY.
ONE INDIVIDUAL ONE PERSON NOT A
GROUP OF OTHER PERSONS NOT A
COMEDIAN YOU HAVE A COMMITTEE IS
GONNA BE CHAIR SOMEBODY'S GONNA
BE IN CHARGE OF SOMETHING AROUND
HERE.
AND SO ON THIS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL D. D. THE
CHIEF JUSTICE THIS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IN IN IN THE
COURSE THEY WILL WE'LL PROBABLY
DO IN A LIFETIME.
WE GOT TO GET IT RIGHT NO MATTER
WHAT HAPPENS IN TWENTY TWENTY IF
IF WE'RE ABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL
TO KEEP MOVING FORWARD.
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE A HEAD START
ON IT.
SO WE'RE NOT STARTING FROM THE
BEGINNING BUT MORE IMPORTANT.
WE'RE NOT HAVING A DISCUSSION.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CAN YOU GIVE
US A FLUSH TO HER -- UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO WHAT WHAT
WILL HAPPEN NEXT WHO'S ON FIRST
BASE HOW WOULD THE MONEY.
BE SPENT AND HOW YOU TO PUT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND
FOLLOW UP SO YOU CAN COME BACK
TO THIS COMMITTEE SO WE'RE NOT
TO GIVE YOU.
GIVE YOU ADVICE OR GIVE YOU MORE
MONEY OF WHAT EVERY WEEK NEED TO
DO TO MAKE SURE THIS IS THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM.
IN THE COUNTRY SO HOPEFULLY WHEN
WE SEE YOU AGAIN.
YOU'LL HAVE A NAME.
IN A POSITION FOR ME.
OKAY.
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR COMMENTS I THINK -- ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE IS THAT
THERE WAS SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS PUT IN THE BUDGET
WITHOUT A PLAN.
AND EVEN THOUGH YOU'VE GIVEN US
SOME GOOD INFORMATION FOR MOST
OF US WE STILL WANT TO SEE THE
PLAN. ONE OF WRITTEN DOWN AS TO
HOW IT OPERATES WHERE IT GOES SO
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY WITH THE AND
THE UNFORTUNATE.
FACT THAT IS BE TEN IS BEING
HELD AT GIVE THIS UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO THEN.
FASHION A A REAL CLEAR PLAN AND
AND HOPEFULLY SOME
IMPLEMENTATION AN ASSESSMENT OF
WHAT CURRENTLY EXIST.
WE ARE ACCORDING TO YOU THEIR
NUMBER OF THESE PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY IN EXISTENCE.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT HOW EFFECTIVE
THEY ARE A HOW EXTENSIVE THEY
ARE.
OR WHETHER PEOPLE HAVE JUST
LABELED IT AS PRE TRIAL BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANY PLACE ELSE
TO PUT IT A CALL IT -- BUT I
THINK WE WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
IS A COMMITTEE FOR THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IS OBVIOUSLY MORE DETAILS -- WHO
IS THIS WHERE IS IT GOING TO BE
WHO?
YOU HAVE WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR
I'M SURE SOMEBODY KNOWS WHO'S
GOING TO BE RESPONSIBLE BUT ALSO
WHAT WE'RE ASSESSING WE'RE WE'RE
OF WITH THE ASSESSMENT SHOULD BE --
WHAT HAVE WE DONE THAT'S GOOD
ALREADY?
WHAT DO WE NEED TO CHANGE WHAT
WORKS IN SMALL AREAS WHICH WORKS
IN LARGE COMMUNITIES -- IS IT IS
IT OKAY TO USE OUR TO PROBATION
DEPARTMENT OR DO OUR OTHER AREAS
WORKING BETTER WE NEED TO KNOW
THAT SO.
OUR CHARTS TO YOU BEFORE WE DO
ANYTHING WITH THIS IS TO GIVE US
A PLAN.
OF A ANSWERING THE ISSUES THAT
THE MEMBER SUPPORT FOR AN
ANSWERING THE ISSUES THAT LA --
HAS PUT FORTH OF IF WE'RE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS PROPOSAL
I THINK IT IS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD.
BUT IT WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
US TO MOVE FOR WITH THAT PLAN --
THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
I'M SURE SOMEBODY AT THAT HAS A
WHOLE LIST OF WHAT THEY COULD DO
IT WITH A BUNCH OF COURT
REPORTER SO WHATEVER.
SO LET'S HOPE THAT WE GET THAT
WE GET A UNDERSTANDING OF IT IN
A THOROUGH PLAN AS TO WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AND WHO'S GOING
TO DO IT.
AND WHAT WE HOPE TO ACCOMPLISH
AND WHAT OUR GOALS ARE SO THE WE
KNOW WITH THE NOT WE'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL THEY SAY IF YOU DON'T
KNOW WHERE YOU GO ON IN A ROW TO
TAKE YOU THERE.
CLEARLY IF WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE'RE ASSESSING EVERYTHING WILL
LOOK LIKE SUCCESS -- SO AS A
RESULT WE NEED A LOT MORE DETAIL
THANK YOU ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD HOPEFULLY
IT'S NOT REAL LONG.
THAT ITS BRIEF YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE TO TELL US YOUR BRILLIANT
IDEA GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
LIST BUT THAT'S BEEN A SAY HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES THE COUNTY HAS SPENT
A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME.
EVALUATING ITS OWN A RESPONSE TO
NEW CRIMINAL JUSTICE
RESPONSIBILITIES -- UP TO AND
INCLUDING -- THE BEST WAY TO
MAKE PRE TRIAL DETENTION
DECISIONS AND KEEPING THOSE IN
CUSTODY ONLY THOSE WHO ARE
REALLY NEED TO BE THERE BECAUSE
OF THE REST THAT'S POSED.
OF LEAVING OBVIOUSLY QUITE A
SIGNIFICANT POPULATION WHO CAN
BE SAFELY RELEASED INTO THE
COMMUNITY -- AS A RESULT THE
COUNTY IS VERY INTERESTED IN
SUPPORT OF OF THE GOVERNOR'S
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION.
DEVOTED TO THE PRE TRIAL --
SERVICES PROJECTS THERE BEEN
CONVERSATIONS LOCALLY BETWEEN
THE COURT IN THE COUNTY I'M SO
WE WOULD JUST WE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION TODAY.
AND WOULD ASK THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO GIVE CONSIDERATION TO
APPROPRIATELY RESOURCING ALL OF
THE PARTNERS WHO WOULD BE
WORKING LOCALLY TO ENSURE THAT A
GOOD SERVICES AND SUPPORTS ARE
GIVEN IN THE COMMUNITY. TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE GOOD
OUTCOMES -- AND THANK YOU WOULD
BE INTERESTED IN CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION AS FURTHER DETAILS
ARE PUT TO THE DESIGN.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ WITH THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA -- HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL -- AS
WAS PREVIOUSLY NOTED THE VAST
MAJORITY OF COUNTIES IN THE
STATE ARE CURRENTLY OPERATING --
A PRE TRIAL PROGRAM I CERTAINLY
WE RECOGNIZE THERE'S DISCUSSIONS
AROUND HOW THAT LOOKS AND
RESPONSIVE.
TO LOCAL DYNAMICS BUT PROBATION
HAS BEEN WORKING IN THIS SPACE
FOR MANY MANY YEARS -- WE ALSO --
KIND OF SHARE A UNIQUE SPACE
WITH -- WORKING WITH THE COURTS --
THE COUNTIES STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS -- IN THIS AREA AND
SO WE CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING PART OF THE CONVERSATIONS --
AS WAS STATED EARLIER IT REALLY
IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THERE
IS SIGNIFICANT CASE LAW IN THIS
AREA ANDSO -- THE IMPACTS ARE
ALREADY HAPPENING -- STATEWIDE
AND LOCALLY THAT REALLY DO
NECESSITATE TAKING A LOOK AT HOW
BEST TO MOVE FORWARD ON PRE
TRIAL PRACTICES -- I THINK
THERE'S A FEW KEY THINGS THAT WE
WANT TO KEEP IN MIND CERTAINLY
WE WANT TO BE RESPONSIVE TO A
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND
DEVELOPING PRE TRIAL PRACTICES
BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF UNIFORMITY -- AND
HAVING DOT AN OUTCOME TO GUIDE
SOME OF THESE DISCUSSIONS I
TOWARDS THAT END -- THAT YOU
PROVISIONAL OFFICERS DID WORKING
COORDINATION WITH THE PRE TRIAL
JUSTICE INSTITUTE WHICH IS A
NATIONALLY KNOWN EXPERT IN AND
PRE TRIAL PRACTICES ON A TOOL
KIT TO REALLY LOOK AT BEST
PRACTICES IN IMPLEMENTING THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS -- I WE'VE
WE'VE SHARED IT AND WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO DO SO AGAIN I'M REALLY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE AS
PROBATION ARE ARE MOVING FORWARD
WITH ALL OF THE AGAIN BEST
PRACTICES TRAINING AND THE
VARIOUS DYNAMICS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED HEREIN COMMITTEE TODAY.
THANK YOU MUCH CERTAINLY SO --
YOUR SUPPORT LOOK FOR TO BE PART
OF A CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIFFANY RIGHT
WITH THAT CA YOU CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL -- AS
YOU GUYS KNOW THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS SO WE WOULD CONCUR WITH
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE LA --
AT THAT THERE'S MORE DETAILS I
NEED TO BE FLUSHED OUT HERE AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THOSE
DETAILS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK FROM CRUISE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY -- WERE
ECHOING THE COMMENTS FROM
ELISABETH FOR LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT OF THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR PRE TRIAL RISK
PROJECTS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS.
AND MOVES A STATE ISSUE NUMBER
THREE THANK YOU THAT ITEMS HELD
OVER UNTIL WE GET A MORE
DETAILED.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE -- THE
DISCOUNTS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE
.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MEMBERS
THIS IS LIKE OF EUROPE WHICH CAN
FROM THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL -- IN
BRIEF -- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION OF FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO JUST DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IN THE TRIAL COURTS.
AND THE PUBLIC COURSE THE FUNDS --
WILL SUPPORT FIRE ALARM SYSTEM
REPAIR AND REPLACEMENT AND IN
THE EVENT YOU DO HAVE QUESTIONS
WE HAVE MY COURT IN HERE TO
EXPAND ON THE PROPOSAL IF
NECESSARY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE HELLO.
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS AT THE
REQUESTED AMOUNT WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTS SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE IN TWO AREAS
AND THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
ACTUALLY CONSISTENT ACROSS ALL
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE RECEIVING
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE MONEY.
SO THE FIRST SET OF RECOMMENDED
AS ARE ALL WOULD REQUIRE THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH TO REPORT BY
JANUARY FIRST -- TWENTY TWENTY
THREE ON HOW THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG HAS CHANGED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TO
THE EXTENT THE BACKLOG HAS GROWN
THE LANGUAGE RIVER WERE WOULD
REQUIRE THE JUDICIAL BRANCH TO
REPORT ON THE REASONS FOR THAT
GROWTH.
AND THE STEPS IT PLANS ON TAKING
TO ADDRESS IT ON AN ONGOING
BASIS OR WHETHER ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATIVE ACTION IS NECESSARY.
THE SECOND AS ARE ALL UP SECOND
SET A RECOMMENDED US ARE ALL
WOULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO SIMILARLY SUBMIT A
REPORT.
BY JANUARY FIRST -- TWENTY
TWENTY THREE ON THE ACTUAL
PROJECTS THAT WERE SUPPORTED
USING THESE DOLLARS AND THIS
WOULD JUST HELP ENSURE THAT THE
MONIES WERE USED CONSISTENT WITH
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS THE MEMBERS.
OKAY IN A QUESTION FROM THE
AUDIENCE COMMENTS.
OKAY FINE I THINK IT'S FAIRLY
CLEAR TERMS WHAT BEING ASKED IN
TERMS OF OTHER PROPOSAL WITH
REGARDS TO REPORTING OUT IN
TERMS OF HOW FAR YOU'VE GONE AND
WHAT AND WHY IN THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT ARE REASONABLE.
OKAY LET'S MOVE THE ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR IT'S HELD OVER.
ISSUE FOR DEALS WITH VARIOUS
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS.
IN EVERY FOR HAVING THE THE THE
SERGEANT HAD TO JUST TAKE
PROVIDING A HAND OUT AS AN
OVERVIEW OVER A BCP'S ALMOST
SPEAK TO THEM AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL PRIORITIES THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED.
NOT FOCUSING ON THE IMF THE
IMPROVING THE MODERNIZATION FUND
AND THE TWO BCP'S THAT ARE
RELATED TO THIS.
I'M ALL START WITH THE BC PEAS
AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE THE
NEED FOR THEM SO THE FIRST IS A
AN ONGOING AUGMENTATION OF FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND. TO SUPPORT THE
DEFENSE AN INDEMNITY OF ALL A
JUDICIAL BRANCH ENTITIES THIS
WOULD HELP OFFSET COSTS IN THE I
MF OF A FIVE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS.
THE NEXT ISSUE IS AN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PHOENIX
ROAD MAP INCLUDING SEVEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS A GENERAL
FUND -- AND THIS IS TO MAINTAIN
AND UPGRADE THE FENIX --
ENTERPRISE RESOURCE.
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AS WELL AS
SUPPORT THE Và CONTINUED
ROLLOUT OF THE STATEWIDE HUMAN
RESOURCES PAYROLL SOLUTION THIS
WILL ALSO PROVIDE RELIEF TO THE
IMPROVEMENT MODERNIZATION FUN.
WHY THESE NECESSARY -- LIKE MANY
STATE FUNDS -- THE IMPROVEMENT
MODERNIZATION FIND RELIES ON
FINES AND FEES -- MANY OF THEM --
CRIMINAL BASED AND THOSE RE
DECLINING REVENUES IN AN EFFORT
TO END TO ENSURE SOLVENCY OF THE
FUND AND MAINTAIN CRITICAL --
EXPENDITURES OUT OF THESE FUNDS
TO SUPPORT THE TRIAL COURT'S --
THESE -- BCP'S -- ARE NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT MOMENT SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT -- AS WE
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS -- THIS
BUDGET CYCLE.
HEY MAKE COMMENTS IN FINANCE HOW
MUCH I'M WORTH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- AS WAS NOTED THAT
IMPROVE AND MODERNIZATION FUND
OR THE I AM UP AS WHAT WE CALL
IT RECEIVES REVENUES FROM FINES
AND FEES FROM CRIMINAL CASES.
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT PROBABLY
PLENTY OF TIMES IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
THOSE REVENUES HAVE CONTINUED
DECLINE I WILL JUST NOTE THAT --
YOU KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
WELL AWARE OF THIS AND WE ARE
TRACKING AND AND I THINK IN
RECOGNITION OF THE LA WAS
RECOMMENDATION THAT I THINK MORE
WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE
HOLISTICALLY BEFORE WE START.
DEPOSITING INDIVIDUAL FINDING
FEES AND TO THE GENERAL FUND --
BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
MONITORING.
OKAY COMING FROM LA -- WE DON'T
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE TWO
PROPOSALS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
YOUR AGENDA BECAUSE WE DID FIND
THAT THEY WERE JUSTIFIED ON A
WORKLOAD BASIS AND ARE NEEDED
FOR JUDICIAL BRANCH OPERATIONS.
WE DO HAVE LARGER CONCERNS ABOUT
THE IMPROVEMENT AND
MODERNIZATION FUND -- AND SO ONE
THING THAT WE WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
IS THAT THIS ONE HAS
CONSISTENTLY HAD OPERATION FOR
FALLS IN ABSENT ANY ACTIONS OF
LIKELY TO GO INSOLVENT IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THE STATE
HAS ACTUALLY TAKEN ACTIONS AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER YEARS TO HELP
WITH THE SOLVENCY OF THIS OF FOR
EXAMPLE THE COST OF OTHER
PROGRAMS HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
SHIFTED TO THE GENERAL FUND AS
WELL.
ON TOP OF THAT AS IS -- IS LAID
OUT ON PAGE TEN OF YOUR AGENDA --
THE LEGISLATURE REALLY HAS
LITTLE OVERSIGHT OVER AT THE IMF
EXPENDITURES THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
GENERALLY REPORTS AFTER THE
EXPENDITURES HAVE BEEN MADE.
AND ON TOP OF THAT THE JUDGE THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH HAS OFTENTIMES
STRUGGLED TO MATCH EXPENDITURES
TO REVENUES AND AND WE WOULDN'T
KNOWLEDGE THAT THE DECLINE IN
CARMEL FIND A REFER FEE REVENUE
IS OUTSIDE OF THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH IS HANDS.
SO TO ADDRESS THE INSOLVENCY
ISSUE ANTEL INCREASE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT WE DO OFFER THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE FIRST RECOMMENDATION IS TO
DEPOSIT -- I AM F. REVENUES INTO
THE GENERAL FUND ELIMINATE THE
IMF.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF FUNDING TO PROVIDE TO
THE PROGRAM'S IRRESPECTIVE.
OF THE AMOUNT OF CARMEL FINE IF
YOU REVENUE THAT'S COMING IN.
AND IT WOULD ELIMINATE THE NEED
TO CONSISTENTLY IDENTIFY
SOLUTIONS TO DEAL WITH I AM UP
SOLVENCY.
THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION IS --
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO DIRECT
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH TO REPORT ON
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE RECEIVING
I AM UP SUPPORT.
BY DECEMBER FIRST HAND SO THAT
GIVE THEM SOME TIME TO KIND OF
JUSTIFY THE PROGRAMS AND HELP
THE LEGISLATURE EVALUATE THEM
AND DETERMINE WHAT LEVEL OF
FUNDING IS APPROPRIATE.
OUR THIRD RECOMMENDATION IS THAT
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS
OFTEN GONNA TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME SO IN THE MEANTIME FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR WE WOULD RECOMMEND
PROVIDING ONE TIME FUNDING SO
THEY CAN MOVE FORWARD WHILE THE
ASSESSMENTS TAKING PLACE.
AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE CUT
CONSISTENT WITH OUR BROADER
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO
IMPROVING THE STATE'S COME OFF I
ENVY SYSTEM [inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS A QUESTION FOR
MEMBERS.
OF THE SYSTEM THAT I WOULD JUST
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH THAT LAST
POINT AND WITH THE CHIEF JUSTICE
MENTIONING THE PROBLEMS WITH THE
FINES AND THE SYSTEM.
IN HER STATE OF THE JUDICIARY
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE COMPONENTS
EVERY PLACE THAT IS FUNDED BY
THOSE FINES AND FEES.
WE NEED TO TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT
IS IF WE'RE GOING.
TO APPROPRIATELY REMOVE THE
JUDICIAL BRANCHES RELIANCE ON
FINES AND FEES WE WE HAVE TO
HAVE A VERY CLEAR SENSE OF WHAT
IT IS WERE FUNDING AND WHY WHAT
ALL THOSE PROGRAMS ARE.
AND THEN STOP THIS RELIANCE ON A
SYSTEM THAT'S BECOME REALLY
UNFAIR AND UNFAIR TO TO THE
PEOPLE WHO RELY ON THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM TO TO BE FAIR.
SO THAT I THINK THAT POINT IS
WELL TAKEN THAT WE SHOULD LOOK
AT PROGRAMS WHAT THEIR EXPENSES
ARE AND NOT NECESSARILY RELY ON
THAT OLD STRUCTURE FROM.
ANY OF THE COMMENTS.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE I
THINK -- A WE AGREE WITH THAT
THAT OF THE I AM A FUN CONTINUES
EVERY YEAR TO HAVE SOME ISSUES
AND ANYTHING THAT'S FUNDED NOW
BY FINES AND FEES SINCE WE
DECIDED THAT QUITE OFTEN THOSE
FINES AND FEES OR UNFAIR AND SO
WITH.
HAVING PEOPLE WHO CAN'T AFFORD
TO BEAR THE BURDEN OF THE SYSTEM --
AND THIS IS A REAL REFLECTION OF
THAT THAT AT SOME POINT WOULD
HAVE TO MAKE SOME DECISION I
DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO GET
ANY BETTER.
ESPECIALLY SINCE EVERYONE IS
DECIDED THAT THE SYSTEM OF FINES
AND FEES IS OFTEN UNFAIR AND
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WAYS.
TO HELP PEOPLE HAVE THEIR DAY IN
COURT AND JUSTICE WITHOUT HAVING
TO HAVE SUCH FINES AND FEES ALL
THE TIME.
UP SAYS HE THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD
TO PAY.
FOR SO AS A RESULT IT PUTS THE
ALL THOSE COOL SOURCES.
INTO OF JEOPARDY AND I KNOW
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS A LOT.
TO THE EXTENT THAT PROBABLY AD
NAUSEUM WE REMEMBER THOUGH WHO
GETS A PENNY WHO GETS THREE
PENNIES ARGUES FOR PENNIES FROM
IS JUST A A SYSTEM ITSELF THAT
IS.
IS JUST.
A IT IT PROBABLY TAKES MORE
MONEY TO MAINTAIN ALL THOSE
LITTLE NUMBERS AND IT DOES WHAT
WE GET OUT OF IT SO I KNOW THAT.
BUT CLEARLY -- THAT'S SOMETHING
WE WILL CONSIDER BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S IT'S GETTING TO THE POINT
WHERE -- IT'S ASYSTEM THAT IS
BROKEN AND IT'S NOT GONNA REPAIR
ITSELF THAT'S CLEAR.
YOUR COMMENTS ANYONE FROM THE
AUDIENCE.
IT MOVES TO THE FINAL ITEM WITH
NUMBER FIVE DEPENDENCY COUNCIL
AND EQUAL ACCESS FUND
[inaudible]
LESLIE STAR.
HI I'M HI MODES I LOVE HIM UP
FROM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND GERRY SMITH IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LEGAL SERVICES OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WELCOME.
YOUR MINISTER YEAH OKAY IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHICHEVER ONE
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LESLIE HI MY FROM CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT ALL OF THE CHILDREN IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM IN LOS
ANGELES SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER
COUNTIES FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE -- FOR ALL THE
SUPPORT YOU'VE PROVIDED OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
WE'RE ALSO GRATEFUL TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS ADDED
TO THE DEPENDENCY COUNCIL BUDGET.
IN THE JANUARY BUDGET AND WHILE
THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS WE STILL HAVE A WAYS TO
GO TO REACH THE RECOMMENDED
MAXIMUM CASELOAD OF A HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE CLIENTS.
HER ATTORNEY IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL TO UNDERSTAND THAT
SERVING THE MOST FRAGILE AND
COMPLEX CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN
OUR STATE IS EXPENSIVE -- IT
WOULD AND I'D LIKE TO GIVE TWO
QUICK EXAMPLES OF HOW THAT HAS
PLAYED OUT FOR US CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER HAS BEEN FORTUNATE TO
BE THE BENEFICIARY OF SEVERAL
GRANT FUNDED OF GRANT FUNDING
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO CREATE
SOME PROJECTS WITH. ONE IS
CALLED THE CARE PROGRAM THE GOAL
OF THAT PROGRAM IS TO AND THE
FOSTER CARE TO PRISON PIPELINE.
IN THAT PROGRAM WE'VE SERVED A
HUNDRED AND FORTY CHILDREN OVER
THE PAST THREE YEARS AND KEEPING
IN MIND WE HAVE THIRTY THOUSAND
CHILD CLIENTS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
SO WE SERVED A HUNDRED AND FORTY
CHILDREN ALL WHO ALL OF WHOM
WERE IN FOSTER CARE AND THEY
WERE SUBSEQUENTLY ARRESTED AND
WE'RE FACING A DELINQUENCY
PROCEEDINGS.
THAT PROJECT IS STAFFED BY TWO
ATTORNEYS THREE CASE MANAGERS
SEVERAL MSW AND AND SEVERAL MSW
INTERNS OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS OF SERVING THOSE HUNDRED
AND FORTY CHILDREN.
WE'VE HAD ONE CHILD AND UP IN
ADULT JAIL WE'VE HAD TO END UP
IN CAMP 86% OR IN SCHOOL OR HAVE
COMPLETED HIGH SCHOOL AND
THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION.
BOTH IN SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND IN
NEED FOR PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION
WERE EXTREMELY PROUD OF THOSE
RESULTS AND IT'S PRETTY
REMARKABLE THAT ONLY ONE OF THE
HUNDRED AND FORTY HAS MADE THEIR
WAY INTO THE ADULT.
PENAL SYSTEM.
BUT WE COULD NEVER DO IT ON OUR
STATE FUNDING BECAUSE OUR STATE
CASELOADS ARE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT CLIENTS.
FOR ONE ATTORNEY AND THIS
PROJECT TAKE SIX SEVEN ADULTS ON
PAID ON THE SALARY ON ON PAYROLL --
TO SERVE A HUNDRED AND FORTY BUT
IT'S SUCCESSFUL AND WE WANT TO
BE TO DO MORE OF THAT BUT WE
CAN'T ON THE CURRENT BUDGET
REQUIREMENTS.
THE CARD CURRENT BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS SIMILARLY AND ARE
SPECIALIZED COURT FOR CHILDREN
WHO ARE VICTIMS OF TRAFFICKING
WE HAVE AGAIN A TEAM OF TWO
ATTORNEYS TO CASE MANAGERS AND
ONE SURVIVOR ADVOCATE BETWEEN
THEM SERVING A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY YOUNG WOMEN -- WHICH AND
WE'RE BEGINNING TO SEE RESULTS
THAT PROJECT IS NEWER -- AND
IT'S AND IT'S A MUCH HEAVIER
LEFT HONESTLY TO HELP THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE -- CHANGE THEIR
LIVES AND CHANGE THEIR
SITUATIONS BUT WE'RE OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH SO FAR AND AGAIN
COULD NEVER DO THAT WITHOUT
GRANT FUNDING WHICH IS GREAT FOR
SEATING AND GREAT FOR PILOTING
AND FOR EXPLORING -- OPTIONS IN
SERVING OUR CLIENTS BUT IT CAN'T
SUSTAIN SOMETHING LONG TERM.
SO OUR FIELD IS IS WE'VE LEARNED
SO MUCH IN THE PAST FIVE TO TEN
YEARS AND AS A COMMUNITY WERE
POISE. TO PUT EMERGING BEST
PRACTICES INTO PLACE BUT WE
CANNOT MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT
ADEQUATE FUNDING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS GERRY SMITH AND I AM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF LEGAL
SERVICES OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS A NON PROFIT THAT
PROVIDES FREE CIVIL LEGAL
SERVICES.
EARLY IN THE AREAS OF HOUSING
HEALTH -- PUBLIC BENEFITS AND
CIVIL RIGHTS TO POOR AND
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS AND
GROUPS TWENTY THREE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES INCLUDING
SACRAMENTO I'M ALSO HERE ON
BEHALF OF LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA.
WHICH INCLUDES NINETY FIVE LEGAL
SERVICES PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE WHICH LIKE MY ORGANIZATION
ALSO RECEIVE EQUAL ACCESS PHONE
SUPPORT -- I WANT EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THE INCREASES IT HAS PROVIDED TO
THE A. F. OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS.
AFTER THAT APPROPRIATIONS BUT
STAGNANT FOR FOR MANY YEARS --
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
THE LAST YEAR THAT DATE IS
AVAILABLE -- THOSE NINETY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS WITHIN LACK SERVED
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CLIENTS.
OF WHOM OVER SIXTY THOUSAND
WE'RE SENIORS OVER EIGHTY
THOUSAND WERE PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND NEARLY TEN
THOUSAND WERE VETERANS WE ALSO
SERVED OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
YOUNGER PERSONS UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN AS INDIVIDUAL CLIENTS
NOT CONNECTED AS CHILDREN WITH
RESPECT TO AN ADULT HEADED --
HOUSEHOLD.
I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT -- THE LEGAL SERVICES
COMMUNITY FOR SERVICE AS THE
FIRST LEGAL RESPOND ORDERS WHEN
DISASTERS STRIKE.
MY ORGANIZATION ASSISTED OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS IN
NOVEMBER AND DECEMBER OF LAST
YEAR ALONE.
AT LOCAL DISASTER CENTERS
FOLLOWING -- THAT THE CAMPFIRE
IF YOU COUNTY AND WE SERVED OVER
THREE HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOLLOWING THE
CAR FIRE IN SHASTA COUNTY A
LITTLE EARLIER AND MY COLLEAGUES
AT LEGAL SERVICES ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- HAVE
SERVE THOUSANDS OF DISASTER
VICTIMS AS WELL -- OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS IN CINEMA AND
NAPA AND COUNTIES IN VARIOUS
PLACES IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND YET OUR STATE STILL AS A
HUGE GAP BETWEEN THE IT'S LEGAL
SERVICES RESOURCES AND THE
DEMAND FOR OUR SERVICES. FOR
EVERY CLIENT WE SERVE WE TURN
AWAY AS MANY AS TEN OTHERS FOR
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH FEWER
SERVICES AS THEY REQUIRE FOR
SOLUTION.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE FEDERAL
LEGAL SERVICES CORPORATION
ESTMATED THAT NATION WIDE 71%
OF ALL LOW INCOME FAMILIES ARE
PERSONS ANNUALLY EXPERIENCE A
SIGNIFICANT LEGAL PROBLEM.
AND 86% OF THOSE PERSONS ARE
UNABLE TO ACCESS A LAWYER AT ALL
TO HELP THEM RESOLVE IT.
AND AS MOST OF YOU ARE AWARE WE
CANNOT COUNT ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR HELP TO CLOSE
THIS GAP -- A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO THE WHITE HOUSE SUBMITTED
ITS TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
PROPOSAL. TO CONGRESS AND FOR
THE THIRD CONSECUTIVE YEAR THE
PRESIDENT -- PROPOSES ZERO
FUNDING FOR THE FEDERAL LEGAL
SERVICES CORPORATION.
HIS EFFORT TO ABOLISH JEALOUSY --
THE FIRST TWO YEARS WAS THWARTED
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF A TWO YEAR
BUDGET DEAL THAT CONGRESS MADE.
IN THE WANING DAYS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION -- BUT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THIS CURRENT YEAR --
THE ELEVEN LSC FUNDED PROGRAMS
IN OUR STATE OF WHICH MY
ORGANIZATION IS.
ONE RECEIVED.
A TOTAL OF THREE MILLION DOLLARS
LESS THAN WE DID IN -- TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BECAUSE OF CENSUS
REDISTRIBUTIONS THAT -- SENSES --
RELATED REDISTRIBUTIONS THAT --
LSC WAS MAKING NATIONALLY SO
WE'RE STILL -- LOSING MONEY ON
THE FEDERAL SIDE.
THIS YEAR WE ANTICIPATE TO
TWENTY TWENTY FEDERAL BUDGET
PROCESS WILL BE MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT THAN IT WAS EVEN LAST
YEAR.
THE TWENTY ELEVEN RECESSION ERA
BUDGET REDUCTIONS.
REQUIRED BUDGET THAT REDUCTIONS
AS PART OF THAT SO CALLED
SEQUESTRATION LEGISLATION COMES
BACK INTO PLACE.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THOSE THOSE
ARE MANDATORY 10% REDUCTIONS IN
LESS A LOT OF HOOPS ARE JUMPED
THROUGH -- AND WE WE BELIEVE
THAT THE LIKELIHOOD OF ANOTHER --
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN IS
IS VERY HIGH OVER -- THIS COMING
YEARS -- BUDGET -- SO WE ARE
HERE TO SUPPORT AND DIGITAL
INCREASING CALIFORNIANS EF --
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR THE
DISTRIBUTION OVERSIGHT OF THESE
FUNDS -- OVER THE LAST SIX
MONTHS OF VERY VERY CAREFUL
REVIEW OF THE STATE'S DECADES
LONG SYSTEM OF LEGAL SERVICES
FUNDING ADMINISTRATION WAS
COMPLETED.
UNDER THE AUSPICES OF OUR STATE
BAR -- AND IT WAS FOUND THAT THE
THE THE SYSTEM OF FUNDING
ADMINISTRATION THROUGH THE LEGAL
SERVICES A TRUST FUND COMMISSION.
IS CREDIBLE AND EFFICIENT.
LASTLY I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THE STATE LEGAL SERVICES
COMMUNITY IS I THINK A CRITICAL
PARTNER.
OF THIS LEGISLATURE.
EVERY YEAR THIS LEGISLATURE AN
AXE AND THE GOVERNOR SIGNS
DOZENS OF NEW LAWS THAT ARE --
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF POOR AND
DISADVANTAGED CALIFORNIANS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
IN AREAS LIKE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND EDUCATION AND CIVIL RIGHTS
AND HEALTH CARE AND AN EMPLOYEE
FOR AND CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
PUBLIC BENEFITS AND IF THE
TARGETS OF THOSE VARIOUS
OBLIGATIONS WHICH THIS
LEGISLATURE IMPOSES EVERY YEAR --
LOCAL GOVERNMENT YOUR
RESTRICTIONS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AND FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS.
FINANCE COMPANIES.
IF IF THESE ENTITIES IGNORE OR
FAIL TO COMPLY WITH THE LAWS
THAT YOU ALL AN ACT THEN THE
LEGISLATURE HIS ENACTED.
HOLLOW PROMISES.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DID NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES OR THE COMMUNITY
PRESENTS TO MONITOR COMPLIANCE
WITH ALL OF THESE LAWS.
AND SO IT IS THE STATE WIDE
LEGAL AID COMMUNITY FUNDED IN
PART BY THE EQUAL ACCESS FUND
WHICH SERVES AS THIS
LEGISLATURE'S PRIVATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. TO ENSURE THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND ENFORCEMENT
OF THIS LEGISLATORS WILL EVERY
YEAR YOU WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
FINES AND FEES AND CHANGES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MADE TO THEM.
MY ORGANIZATION HAS GONE INTO
THE SUPERIOR COURTS OF VERY
HELPFUL HOST EVERY COURT IN
MIGHT JURISDICTION -- TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY WERE NOT IGNORING
THE CHANGES THAT YOU MADE TO THE
FINES AND FEES SYSTEMS WHICH I
CAN SADLY TELL YOU THEY WERE
UNTIL THEY WERE PRODDED INTO
COMPLIANCE -- SO WE WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE WE BELIEVE TO
TRY AND EFFECTUATE THE WILL OF
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE GROUND.
IN ALL THE WORK THAT YOU DO SO
WE APPRECIATE THE INCREASES THAT
YOU PROVIDED TO DATE WE HAVE
AMOUNT EQUAL JUSTICE OF AXIS
FUND OF ABOUT FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH WE THINK WOULD
BRING US CLOSER TO COMPLIANCE.
WITH THE THE THE JUSTICE GAP
NEEDS AND WE WILL BE
APPRECIATIVE OF ANY SUPPORT YOU
CAN PROVIDE FOR US THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
THE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
AND WHEN OUR SPEAKER IN HIS
INFINITE WISDOM TOOK THE POLICY
CHAIRS.
PLACE THEM ON THIS BUDGET PENNY
THAT.
MAKE THE BENEFIT THAT WE HAVE IS
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE IN THE
POLICY ROUND BRING IT INTO THE
BUDGET CONTACTS AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
MY LETTER.
WHICH IS ASKING FOR DEPENDENCY
COUNCIL AND FULLY FUNDING IT BY
ADDING THE SIXTY EIGHT MILLION.
ADDING.
COURT REPORTERS WHICH WE DEALT
WITH EARLIER AND AGAIN CREASING
THAT TO THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS AN EQUAL
ACCESS FUNDING.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
COURTS AND COURTS FUNDING THE
BEST WAY WE CAN I THINK FRAME IT
IS AS ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR ALL
OF THOSE IN CALIFORNIA WHO DID
IT?
THE WEALTHIEST AMONG US WILL
ALWAYS FIND A WAY THE POOREST
AMONG US DON'T THEM AND THIS IS
THE THE NEXUS OF POLICY AND
BUDGET.
SO IN JUDICIARY.
WHICH WE OVERSEE THE THE CIVIL
LEGAL SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
WORKING HARD WITH THE STATE BAR
TO ENSURE THAT THEY THAT LAWYERS
ACROSS THE STATE ARE MEETING
THEIR OBLIGATION. TO LEGAL
SERVICES FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS WE
ARE LOOKING AT DIVERSITY WE'RE
LOOKING AT A NUMBER OF THINGS TO
MAKE THE LEGAL PROFESSION.
MORE REPRESENTATIVE OF OF
CALIFORNIA.
SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF THAT IS
THIS LEGAL SERVICES FUNDING IN
ENSURING THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING
ALL OF THOSE NEEDS.
WITH WHETHER IT'S DISASTERS OF A
NATURAL KIND WEATHER'S DISASTERS
OF A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT KIND.
FOR ALL THE OTHER THINGS THAT
OUR FOLKS ARE IN CALIFORNIA ARE
STRUGGLING WITH.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE.
BUILT A SYSTEM THAT GIVES THEM
ACCESS THE DEPENDENCY COUNCIL.
PIECES ONE IT'S VERY CLOSE TO MY
HEART IS YOU PROBABLY KNOWS
WE'VE BEEN.
DEALING WITH THAT SYSTEM.
THESE ARE KIDS THAT DAY AT THE
LEVEL OF SUCCESS THAT DEPENDENCY
COUNCIL HAVE OF HELPING THOSE
KIDS STAY OUT OF FUTURE JUSTICE
ENTANGLEMENTS AND VERY EXPENSIVE
ENTANGLEMENTS.
IS SIGNIFICANT THAT'S WHAT THIS
FUNDING IS IT'S AN INVESTMENT IN
THOSE KIDS AND INVESTMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S WHY I SEE MYSELF AS AS A
A CONDUIT TO THIS ASK FOR A
NUMBER OF THESE AND BRINGING
THEM INTO THE CONVERSATION OF
THIS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AND OUR
ABILITY. TO WORK BOTH ON THE
POLICY SIDE IN THE BUDGET SIDE
TO SOLVE SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S THE ASK IT'S BEEN VERY
WELL ARTICULATED HERE I I'VE
BEEN A PART OF MAKING THIS ASK
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
KEEPING IT ON THE TABLE KEEPING
IT AS A PART OF OF THIS.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AND MADAM
CHAIR I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
YOUR STAFF ALL OF US BEING ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION.
WORK THE DIFFICULT ISSUES THEN
AND AS WE HAVE FUNDS AND AS
OTHERS ARE BACKING OFF LIKE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THEIR
OBLIGATION TO PEOPLE ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
WE'RE HAVING TO FILL SOME OF
THESE GAPS WITH THESE ARE TRUE
INVESTMENTS IN OUR ABILITY TO
SAVE MONEY DOWN THE LINE AND
MAKE THE SYSTEM WORK FOR PEOPLE
SO THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS.
FROM THE AUDIENCE. OH MY
GOODNESS OKAY THOUGH YOU REALLY
DON'T HAVE WITHIN A ONE MAN IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CASH
FOR OF A CUSTOM A STAFF ATTORNEY
AT WITH UNIVERSITY OF PACIFIC
MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW
IMMIGRATION CLINIC.
ARE THE EQUAL ACCESS FUND HAS
GIVEN US CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
FREE LEGAL SERVICES TO LOW
INCOME SACRAMENTUM.
OUT WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
EXIST WITHOUT THIS FUND HERE'S
JUST A SNAPSHOT OF WHAT WE DID
IN THE LAST YEAR.
WE PROVIDED FULL OR LEGAL
REPRESENTATION TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO IMMIGRANT CLIENTS WE HELP
NINETY SIX IMMIGRANTS GET ACCESS
RANGING FROM CITIZENSHIP TO WORK
AUTHORIZATION. TO VICTIM OF
CRIME FEES US THROUGH OUR TENTH
ANNUAL FAIR WE HELPED ABOUT
FIFTY FOLKS NATURALIZED.
WE'VE DONE PRESENTATIONS TO HIGH
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY ARE REACHING SIX HUNDRED
FOLKS -- MOST RECENTLY WOULD
HELP A YOUNG WOMAN RECEIVE HER
PERMANENT RESIDENCY THROUGH A
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT JUVENILE
STATUS PROGRAM.
ONLY A FEW THOUSAND PEOPLE GET
THIS EVERY YEAR SHE WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL WHEN WE STARTED HELPING
HER.
NOW SHE IS WITH CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY PROGRAM STUDYING TO
BECOME A SCHOOL TEACHER -- WITH
AN INCREASE IN THESE EQUAL
ACCESS FUNDS WERE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO HELP EVEN MORE
IMMIGRANTS LIKE THIS YOUNG WOMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
HELLO A NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS THEY JUST
SORT OF A PAIR OF THE CABLE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL -- AM.
I MYSELF EXPERIENCED FOSTER CARE
WHAT AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND
DURING THAT TIME I DON'T HAVE A
CONNECTION WITH MY SOCIAL WORKER
MY FAMILY OR EVEN THE PLACEMENTS
I WAS PLACE THAN IT WAS THAT MY
SEALS THE ATTORNEY.
WHO ACTUALLY KEPT ME GROUNDED
AND OFFERED ME MORE SUPPORT THAN
WHICH SHE COULD EVEN?
KNOWS NOW I'M SHE TURNED ME INTO
THE WOMAN THAT I AM TODAY.
AND I OVER A LOT SO I FEEL LIKE
YOU GUYS SHOULD REALLY SUPPORT
THEM AND GIVE THEM A LITTLE BIT
MORE MONEY BECAUSE THEY
DEFINITELY DESERVE IT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SELLING A
COUPLE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ALL THREE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE'S REQUEST.
THE VERY BRIEFLY ON THE THIRD
REQUEST FOR THE INCREASING EQUAL
ACCESS FUNDS AND MISTER SMITH
EARLIER THAT WE ARE AT RISK OF
PERHAPS A 10% CUT IN FEDERAL
FUNDS.
AND IN CALIFORNIA WE GET ABOUT
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR CIVIL LEGAL
AID SO WE GET A 10% KIND OF THAT.
NEXT YEAR WE'LL SEE A DROP IN
NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
I'M IN SINCE I WORK SO CLOSELY
WITH A NINETY FIVE ACTUALLY NOW
THIS YEAR IT'S NINETY EIGHT
PROGRAMS THAT RECEIVE EQUAL
ACCESS FUNDS WE KNOW HOW
DIFFERENT EVERY SINGLE PROGRAM
IS.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE SUPPORT
LETTERS YOU GOT FROM PROGRAMS
YOU'LL SEE EXAMPLES RANGING FROM
HELPING IMMIGRANTS WITH HIV
GETTING ASYLUM. TO HELPING AND
PROVIDE SERVICES IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SHELTERS ARE IN
HOMELESS SHELTERS HAVING --
HOTLINES THAT COVER SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO EVERY PROGRAM
REALLY IS ABLE TO USE THE FUNDS
TO MEET THEIR LOCAL NEEDS AND
THEY'RE OUT ACTUALLY BUT TO GO
THE COMMUNITIES AND SAY WHAT DO
YOU NEED SERVICES WHETHER IT'S
DISASTERS.
OR TO PERSONAL ORDERS SO WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE ALL
THREE REQUEST THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS HILARY
QUESTIONS FROM DEPENDENCY
ADVOCACY CENTER IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WE REPRESENT PRIMARILY
PARENTS AND SOME CHILDREN IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM.
AND I AM HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO REACH FULLY FUNDED
DEPENDENCY COUNCIL.
I THINK WHAT I CAN DO BEST AS AN
ATTORNEY TO ILLUSTRATE THE
IMPACT AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
DEPENDENCY COUNCIL ON OUR MOST
VULNERABLE FAMILIES IS TO
ACTUALLY BE QUIET -- AND TO TURN
IT OVER TO RUN ME RELEASE WHO IS
HERE AT SHE IS A FORMER CLIENT
OF OUR ORGANIZATION AND SHE IS --
SUCCESSFULLY REUNIFIED WITH HER
CHILD IS AND IS NOW A MENTOR
PARENT WITH OUR ORGANIZATION --
HELPING.
OTHER PARENTS NAVIGATE THROUGH
THE SYSTEM.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RAMY REYES I AM A MENTOR PARENT
THE DEPENDENCY ADVOCACY CENTER
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY -- I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT INCREASED
FUNDING FOR THE DEPENDENCY
ATTORNEYS -- I WAS ARRESTED IN
FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
AND MY SON WAS REMOVED FROM MY
MY PRESENCE.
I A SUMMER SPENT SIX DAYS IN
JAIL AND WHEN I WAS OVER
RELEASED I WAS TOLD TO GO TO A
DETENTION WHERE -- I WOULD FIND
OUT WHAT HAPPENED WHAT HAPPENED
TO ME MY SON.
I WAS SCARED A SHAME CONFUSED
OVERWHELMED AND FULL OF ANXIETY
AS I AM RIGHT NOW -- A LADY
APPROACHED ME AND INTRODUCED
HERSELF AS MY DEPENDENCY
ATTORNEY.
SHE BECAME ONE OF THE KEY PEOPLE
IN MY ROAD TO RECOVERY -- SHE
WILL -- I WAS WITH HER FOR OVER
A YEAR.
AS I COMPLETED MY DEPENDING
DEPENDENCY PROGRAM SHE FULLY
SUPPORTED ME EVEN WHEN I READ
LAPSED.
I WAS ABLE TO TALK WITH HER
ABOUT ANYTHING -- I COMPLETED
SUCCESSFULLY SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETING MY PROGRAM -- ME MY
SON HAVE ONE OF THE STRONGEST
BONDS EVER THAT I FEEL MOTHER
AND A SON CAN HAVE.
MY MAY BE LOW BY SOME ON THAT --
AND FOR YOUR I WAS ABLE TO WORK
WITH -- MY ATTORNEY SIDE BY SIDE
WITH HER -- AS I WAS A MENTOR
PARENT.
AND SHE WOULD INTRODUCED ME AS
ONE OF HER SUCCESS STORIES --
WITHOUT HER HELP AND GUIDANCE
AND KERN SUPPORT I WOULDN'T BE
STANDING HERE TODAY ASKING FOR
YOUR HELP THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALISA
PATTON I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
EAST BAY FAMILY DEFENDERS -- I
OPENED A CO FOUNDED AT EASTBAY
FAMILY DEFENDERS IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO SERVE
ALL THE PARENTS AND SOME
CHILDREN.
IN ALAMEDA COUNTIES DEPENDENCY
COURTS.
AND I A CO FOUNDED EAST BAY
FAMILY DEFENDERS BECAUSE I'M
PASSIONATE ABOUT REPRESENTING
CHILDREN AND PARENTS WHO ARE
CAUGHT UP IN OUR PUBLIC CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM.
AND I'M ALSO PERSUADED -- BY
OVER A DECADE BY MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND ALSO BY OVER A
DECADE OF RESEARCH WHICH HAS
DEMONSTRATED.
THAT -- STRONG HIGH QUALITY
LEGAL REPRESENTATION ACTUALLY
FURTHERS OUR STATE'S CHILD
WELFARE GOALS OF SAFETY
PERMANENCE AND WELL BEING
SPECIFICALLY THERE'S RESEARCH
THAT INDICATES HIGH QUALITY
REPRESENTATION PROGRAMS.
REDUCE SAFELY REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF CHILDREN WHO ENTER FOSTER
CARE SHORTEN THE AMOUNT OF TIME
CHILDREN SPEND IN OUT OF HOME
PLACEMENTS.
INCREASE THE RATE AND SPEED WITH
WHICH CHILDREN ARE REUNIFIED
WITH FAMILIES ARE PLACED ANOTHER
PERMANENT HOMES AND RESULTS AN
OVERALL COST SAVINGS -- THERE
ARE.
IMPORTANTLY ALSO IT INCREASES
THE ACCURACY AND RELIABILITY OF
INFORMATION PER SIDE IT
PRESENTED TO JUDGES WHEN THEY
MAKE LIFE ALTERING DECISIONS
THERE ARE VERY FUTURE DID
JUDICIAL -- CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH A DECISION HAS THE ABILITY
TO DE RAIL A PERSON OF ITS LIFE
POTENTIALLY IN WAYS FROM WHICH
THEY CAN NEVER RECOVER.
AND IT IS IT IT REALLY
IMPERATIVE THAT WE HAVE HIGH
QUALITY REPRESENTATION. TO
INSURE THAT DECISIONS MADE ABOUT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES LIVES ARE
MADE ON THE BEST POSSIBLE THANK
YOU EVIDENCE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CAROLYN
GREECE FOR THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CHILDREN'S LEGAL
SERVICES OF SAN DIEGO WE'RE A
NEW NONPROFIT AS OF TWO YEARS
AGO THAT TOOK OVER
REPRESENTATION FOR THE FOSTER
YOUTH IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
CLOSING ITS DOORS DUE TO FUNDING
ISSUES.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO EXPLAIN HOW
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT CHILDREN CAN BE QUALITY
AND POSSIBLE AND THE THAN MONEY
THAT IS NEEDED FOR THE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVEN MILLION. TO
GET OUR CASELOADS DOWN FORTY
REALLY IS.
BEST EXPRESSED IN THE HOURS THAT
WE CAN DEVOTE TO EACH OF THOSE
SMALL CLIENTS WE HAVE TO SPEAK
IN A TRAUMA INFORMED WAY AT
THEIR LEVELS.
REPRESENT THEIR BEST INTERESTS
AS WELL AS THEIR VOICES WHEN YOU
HAVE A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
CLIENTS.
THAT'S REALLY AN IMPOSSIBLE TASK
TO DO WITH THE QUALITY LEVEL
THOSE CHILDREN DESERVE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
SPEAKING OUT TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA AS WELL AS
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
IN SUPPORT OF THE JUVENILE
DEPENDENCY FUNDING REQUEST
THAT'S BEEN VERY WELL
ARTICULATED BY THE COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S KRISTEN
MUCH HERE AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF EAST BAY CHILDREN'S
LAW OFFICES IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
WE'VE BEEN AROUND FOR ABOUT TEN
YEARS NOW AND RISKS TO HAVE
SERVED ALMOST NINE THOUSAND
CHILDREN OVER THAT TIME.
ANSWER FOR ALMOST FIFTEEN
HUNDRED TODAY AND TO BE ABLE TO
CREATE THE KIND OF RELATIONSHIPS
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT BETWEEN.
ATTORNEYS AND CLIENTS YOU NEED
TO HAVE LOWER CASE LOADS AND YOU
NEED TO HAVE SOME CONSISTENCY
AND REPRESENTATION AT THIS POINT
WE'RE HAVING A REAL FULL HAVING
REAL TROUBLE RETAINING ATTORNEYS
AND KEEPING THEM AROUND FOR
HEARING AFTER HEARING.
AND YEAR AFTER YEAR I TODAY
HEARD FROM A CLIENT WHO I
REPRESENT AND PERSONALLY FOR
EIGHT YEARS -- AND ONLY I CAN
UNDERSTAND THE THINGS SHE'S GONE
THROUGH AND THE WAY THAT I CAN
BECAUSE I'VE KNOWN HER ALL THIS
TIME.
I'M MORE AS WE HAVE ANOTHER
GROUP OF CLIENTS IN OUR OFFICE
WHO ARE ON THEIR THIRD ATTORNEY
IN THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF.
AND THERE'S NO WAY WE CAN HELP
THESE KIDS SUCCEED AND AVOID THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AVOID
EXPLOITATION AVOID ALL THE
THINGS -- ALL THE OBVIOUS
PITFALLS FOR FOSTER YOUTH WHEN
WE DON'T KNOW THEM WELL ENOUGH --
SO WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO RETAIN
OUR STAFF WITH LOW ENOUGH
CASELOADS THEY CAN DO THAT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LISKI AND WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES ARE WE ARE A NONPROFIT
CIVIL RIGHTS LEGAL ORGANIZATION
AND OUR WORK -- IS -- GUIDED BY
THE PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE MAKE
WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS MANY OF THEM --
CLIENTS OF SOME OF THE SERVICES
THAT HAVE SPOKEN TODAY AS YOU
WELL KNOW -- LAWS IN EDUCATION
DON'T IMPLEMENT THEMSELVES AND
VERY OFTEN THE PROMISES FOR
EQUITY -- AND FAIRNESS A REALLY
RELY ON PROVIDING SUPPORT TO
FAMILIES AND STUDENTS -- AND OF
THE EQUAL ACCESS FUND IS HOW WE
CAN DO IT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CRYSTAL HOW THE
AYE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS WITH
THE ACCESS EQUAL ACCESS FUND
MONIES THAT THE ALLIANCE
RECEIVES WE HELP TO SUPPORT.
RELATIVES AND THAT THEIR QUEST
TO KEEP CHILDREN OUT OF FOSTER
CARE WE SUPPORT FOSTER'S
CHILDREN TO ACCESS THE BENEFITS
AND SERVICES THAT THEY NEED WE
ALSO SUPPORT ADOPTIVE PARENTS IN
THEIR QUEST TO ADOPT CHILDREN
OUT OF FOSTER CARE SYSTEM WE
CAN'T DO THAT WITHOUT ACCESS TO
FUNDS WE URGE.
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE APPLICATION
THANK YOU.
I GET AFTERNOON JIMMY FROM IN
FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA.
WHERE THE LARGEST RECIPIENT OF
EQUAL ACCESS FUNDS WHICH WE USED
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT?
ADVOCACY AND LEGAL AID TO
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE THINK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR FOR THE
SUPPORT OF THE FUND.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ON THE WEB
BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE INCREASE INCREASE FOR
EQUAL ACCESS FUNDS.
RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE SOME OF
THE MOST DISADVANTAGED DUE TO
ISOLATION LANGUAGE BARRIERS AND
ALSO FOR IN ELIGIBILITY FOR FOR
LEGAL SERVICES PROGRAM THE EQUAL
ACCESS FUND WILL ENSURE.
ACCESS FOR QUALITY LEGAL
ASSISTANCE AND ADVOCACY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON J. PETERSON ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA INDIAN
LEGAL SERVICES CALIFORNIA INDIAN
LEGAL SERVICES STATEWIDE LEGAL
SERVICES PROGRAM.
SERVING UP INCOME ELIGIBLE.
AMERICAN INDIAN INDIVIDUALS
COMMUNITIES AND TRIBES.
NEARLY A QUARTER OF AMERICAN
INDIANS IN CALIFORNIA QUALIFY
FOR FREE LEGAL SERVICES
CALIFORNIA INDIAN LEGAL SERVICES
RELIES ON THE A A FUNDING TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR CLIENT
COMMUNITY.
AND WE WELCOME OF THE SUPPORT
PROPOSED.
IN THIS BUDGET THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JESSICA MARTINEZ AND I REPRESENT
PARENTS FROM NORTH -- COUNTY
SANTA BARBARA JUST TO BE CLEAR
MY COMMENTS ARE ONLY ABOUT NORTH
COUNTY I DO NOT MAKE ANY
REPRESENTATIONS FOR SOUTH COUNTY --
CURRENTLY NORTH COUNTY COSTS FOR
CASES FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
DOLLARS.
WE ARE NO LONGER FUNDED FOR
INVESTIGATORS WE ARE NO LONGER
FUNDED FOR EXPERTS -- WE HAVE
EIGHT BECAUSE OF THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF NORTHERN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY -- WE ARE IN NEED
OF TRANSLATORS WHICH ARE
CLASSIFIED AS EXOTIC LANGUAGES
FOR BOTH CHILD AND PARENTS.
OUT OF THE FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ONE DOLLARS PER CASE WE
ARE PAYING THE TRANSLATORS WE
ARE PAYING CLERICAL STAFF WE ARE
PAYING.
EXPERTS AND MANY MORE THINGS --
I WATCHED MY COLLEAGUES WORKING
IN THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
CONTINUE TO GET COST OF LIVING.
RAISES I HAVE MYSELF NOT SEEN
THAT I HAVE SEEN THREE CUTS --
YET MY CASELOAD HAS NOT LESSENED.
IT IS NOT STAY THE SAME.
IT IS GOTTEN A MUCH HEAVIER
THREE YEARS AGO I HAD A HUNDRED
AND FORTY CLIENTS AND I AM WELL
OVER THAT SO I AM DEFINITELY IN
SUPPORT OF MORE FUNDING FOR
DEPENDS COUNCIL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRIS
NOT TAUGHT US I'M A RETIRED LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS SERING
FORTY ONE YEARS.
I'VE SEEN FIRST EXPERIENCE OF
FAMILIES IN NEED OF DEPENDENCY
COUNCIL -- CURRENTLY I KNOW FEW
ATTORNEYS -- THE ONE THAT JUST
SPOKE SHE HAS OVER TWO HUNDRED
CLIENTS AND HER COUNSEL AND YOU
WANT OPTIMAL CARE FOR YOUR THE
THE CLIENTS WELL OPTIMAL CARE
MEANS THE BEST.
AND BEST MUSIC THEY HAVE TO
LOWER THEIR CASELOAD AND WITH
THE INCREASE FUNDING THAT WOULD
DO THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR WEBER
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE ON MICHAEL
BURNS ON WITH THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY JUVENILE DEFENSE PANEL.
I'VE BEEN HERE IN YEARS PAST I
THOUGHT WAS IMPORTANT FOR ME TO
COME BACK HERE TODAY TO TELL YOU
THAT THROUGH YOUR WISDOM.
YOU'VE ACTUALLY SAVE SOME LIVES
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY -- THE
INCREASED FUNDING THAT YOU'VE
GIVEN US IN THE PAST YEARS.
HAS BEEN ABLE TO ALLOW US TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THESE
CHILDREN AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
KEEP THEM OUT OF THE DELINQUENCY
SYSTEM.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT AND I
THINK THAT -- IF YOU CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT US AND FUND US.
WE'RE GONNA GET TO A POINT TIME
WE'RE NOT GONNA TALK ABOUT PRE
TRIAL SENTENCING OR SERVICING.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU GO HOME TONIGHT
YOU'VE CHANGED ALLIES OF MANY
CHILDREN MY COUNTY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BILL
SURVEY ON A DEPENDENCY COUNCIL
IN NORTH OF SANTA BARBARA COUNTY.
I GENERALLY REPRESENT PARENTS
BUT I'M ACTIONS SPEAK -- FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WHO REPRESENT
CHILDREN -- OF WHICH THERE ARE --
THREE ATTORNEYS CURRENTLY DOING
THAT -- THE LEVEL OF FUNDING THE
WAY IT'S CURRENTLY ALLOCATED THE
OUR EXISTING ON FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS LESS PER MONTH THAN THEY
DID IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
THERE'S NO LONGER OF ADEQUATE
FUNDING.
FOR INTERPRETERS --
INVESTIGATORS AND IN.
CERTAIN CASES WHERE IT'S EXPERTS
ARE NEEDED FOR THINGS LIKE --
BONDING STUDIES -- OR SPECIAL
CASES WERE WE'RE DEALING WITH --
AUTISTIC CHILDREN -- AND TO THAT
SORT OF THING -- BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THEIR WORK THAT THEY
HAVE.
TO HAVE MORE DIFFICULTY
MAINTAINING AND ESTABLISHING A
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR CLIENTS
THAN WE DO WITH OUR ADULT
CLIENTS.
AND THIS IS REQUIRING BECAUSE OF
THEM BEING UNABLE HIGHER SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE INVESTIGATORS SAY
TRAVEL LITERALLY AROUND THE
STATE TO HAVE TO MEET AND SPEND
TIME WITH THEIR INDIVIDUAL
CLIENTS AND KEEP TRACK THEM --
SO WE ARE URGING -- FULL SUPPORT
FOR THE FUNDING THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MADAM CHAIR BY CAROL WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY I THINK IS THE FIRST
YEAR MAYBE FIVE YEARS.
NOT HERE TALKING ABOUT FINES AND
FEES -- BUT WHICH IS A GOOD
THING FOR WHAT'S RIGHT -- BUT WE
ARE HERE TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR ALL THREE PROPOSALS --
WITHOUT LAWYERS OUR CLIENTS
DON'T GET THE PROTECTION THEY
NEED THEY DON'T GET THE BENEFITS
THAT THEY DESERVE.
AND OUR STATE WILL BE A LESSER
PLACE WITHOUT THAT SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT ALL THREE
PROPOSALS.
SUZANNE AND IF A CHILDREN NOW
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUGMENTATION WERE DEPENDENCY
COUNCIL TO ENSURE THAT YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE GET THE
REPRESENTATION THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR COMING I'D I'M FORTUNE MY
COLLEAGUE MRS STONE IS GONE BUT
WANT TO THANK HIM. FOR HIS
CONSISTENT AND PERSISTENT
RAISING OF THIS ISSUE -- WE KNOW
THE WORK THAT YOU DO IS
EXTREMELY VALUABLE -- THAT --
THERE'S NOTHING MORE FRUSTRATING
THAN TO HAVE.
OF RIGHT ON YOUR SIDE BUT NO ONE
ARTICULATED FOR YOU OR TO HELP
YOU TO ARTICULATED AND SO --
THAT WE HAVE TO DO BECAUSE IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THAT ARE
SQUARE SYSTEM TO WORK THE PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO IT AND HAVE
ACCESS TO THE THINGSTHAT ARE
THERE SO.
I KNOW IN SAN DIEGO THERE IS A
TREMENDOUS DOES -- OUTPOURING OF
APPRECIATION LAST YEAR WHEN THEY
SAW THE BUDGET NAY WERE
EVERYWHERE I WENT I WAS ONE OF
WHAT THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT NOW
I REALIZE OKAY AS WE DID DO
SOMETHING DECENT AND GOOD -- BUT
I THINK WILL CONTINUE TO TRY TO
DO THAT BECAUSE IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT AS WE BEGIN TO TALK
ABOUT HOW CAN WE HELP YOUNG
PEOPLE DEAL WITH THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM.
AS IT IS ONE OF THE WAYS OF
COURSE IS TO HELP THEM TO AVOID.
THE PITFALLS OF IT AND TO NOT
BECOME A PART OF THE WORST PART
OF THAT SYSTEM.
BUT TO FIGURE OUT WAYS IN WHICH
WE CAN HELP THEM TO BUILD
THEMSELVES UP AND I KNOW LEGALLY
DOES A LOT OF WONDERFUL THINGS
FOR THOSE OF US WHO REPRESENT
POOR COMMUNITIES -- IT DOES AN
AMAZING JOB IN HELPING OF FOLKS
DEAL WITH A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THEY JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND.
AND IS REALLY THE ONLY PLACE FOR
THEM TO GO AND I KNOW.
WE WE WERE FOR A LOT OF THEM TO
THEM AND OFFICE BECAUSE IT'S THE
ONLY A HELP IF THEY HAVE WITHIN
NOT DEALING WITH THE A CRIMINAL
ISSUE AND HAVE A PUBLIC DEFENDER
BUT OF SOME OF THE OTHER THE
REAL ISSUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT
IN LIFE.
TAKE PLACE ON THANK ALL OF YOU
WHO CAME AND STAYED TO THE END
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO YOU.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO US AS WELL
SO I REALLY THANK YOU FOR THAT
WITH THAT HAVING BEEN SAID IF WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING ELSE THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU